mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché cadors ma dernière vidéo
je n'ai pas su localiser arago la honte
la honte suprême dernier pas les
odieuses on a le site d'arago magnifique
cible de tautavel
je ne sais pas où est localisée tais toi
toi tu et à toi tu n'as pas su ou et et
arago arago c'est tautavel mais oui bien
sûr bien sûr que cet hôte avait le
regard d ici là cet hominidé la arago
arago sète travail c'est notre bon notre
bonhomme de tautavel notre fierté
nationale
j'ai pas su j'ai passé houleux à la
route à la ronde
donc voilà notre homme de tautavel qui
forment un cloud avec et d'albert
gagnent 6 et voilà je n'ai pas su c'est
dingue c'est la honte intergalactique
donc maintenant il faut que je paye il
faut que je paye et pour payer quoi de
mieux qu'une bonne vidéo créationnistes
des familles bon ben comme d'habitude
cette vidéo je n'ai pas vu parce que je
mate et l'errance à la douleur a ses
limites comme d'habitude et que que
l'art à manger j'ai vraiment pas envie
de la voir façon c'est la règle c'est le
jeu ma pauvre lucette c'est la règle
faut que j'ai pas envie de la voir
focal est à un plus gros succès que la
vidéo que je puisse réaliser par-dessus
300000 vue je crois qu'il ya aucune de
nos vidéos qui aura 320 de vue il ya
cinq mille deux cents personnes qui ont
cliqué j'aime donc j'aimerais quand même
souligner le fait qu'il y à 5200
personnes qui considèrent que le contenu
de cette vidéo est sérieux lisez le
titre preuve que le déluge de noé a
formé le dossier fossiles
[Rires]
le dossier fossiles mais oui donc à
quelqu'un qui a fait tomber un jour un
dossier
voilà dans la terre le prix dans la
taille here il devenait un fossé s
adonnaient le dossier fossiles
c'est quand même le dossier ça pousse
dans la taille here
j'ai pas encore trouvé le nom 5200
personnes
5200 personnes moi j'ai grandi dans un
bled de 700 âmes voir décompte du nombre
c'est agressant voilà il ya cinq mille
deux cents personnes qui ont cliqué
j'aime sur une vidéo qui parle du
dossier fossiles au lieu du registre
fossile oui c'est une erreur de
traduction bête et grâce donc cette
vidéo la raison pour l'armée a envoyé
cette vidéo est la raison pour laquelle
on l'a envoyée c'est que comme vous le
voyez il a été traduit en français donc
je suppose que s'il sera dans les titres
voilà nous allons examiner la
paléontologie du déluge du raid du rêve
ça vient d'eux une chaîne qui s'appelle
is genesis history 1 alors indices faut
éviter de créer des chaînes dont le
titre est une question est dans la
réponse à cette question est non
la genèse n'est pas un événement
historique
je pense que même les plus gros croyants
ne le crois pas mais bref
donc on va se taper preuve que le déluge
de noé a formé le dossier fossiles par
le docteur curt wise may be not so wise
ça ouais bon ça ça répond aux règles
habituelles de débogage et pénitence à
plus de succès que mes propres vidéos
dont je ne fais pas de pub pour un pour
un contenu qui serait illustré mans
inconnue c'est généralement la raison
pour laquelle je ne prends pas vos
vidéos 1
il ya des gens qui sont tellement
gentils avec moi qu'ils m'envoient des
vidéos pour que je souffre en les
regardant
merci c'est sympa ils m'envoient des
vidéos pour des bunkers et pénitence
voilà pour que je souffre en les
regardant
mais alors la plupart des vidéos que
vous m'envoyez soit elles sont beaucoup
beaucoup trop longue
comme celle là est donc déjà je vais
vraiment souffrir elle fait 1h10 cette
vidéo
donc soit elles sont beaucoup beaucoup
trop longue mais surtout elles ont
beaucoup beaucoup pas assez de vue
d'autant que maintenant youtube a
tendance à sanctionner les contenus
conspi et que c'est difficile d'être
créationnistes sans être construit parce
que c'est difficile de croire que le
monde a été créé en une semaine et en
même temps de considérer les
paléontologues comme des gens sérieux ou
honnête donc on vire forcément
conspirent quand on devient
créationnistes parce que je dirais il
n'ya pas d'autre choix que de croire en
un complot maudite mondial de la
paléontologie contre vous donc bref donc
comme youtube a tendance à sanctionner
ces contenus là bas les vidéos
créationnistes deviennent de plus en
plus rare et ça c'est bien
elles sont de goût du coup de moins en
moins vu aussi puisqu'elles sont réglo
des d'une façon différente pour essayer
d'échapper aux règles tout ça mais bref
du coup elles ont moins en moins mieux
mais celle là apparemment elle a échappé
aux elle a échappé au processus où je
vois donc voilà elle a fait plus de vue
que mes vidéos
c'est une vidéo que je n'ai absolument
pas envie de voir que je n'ai pas vu que
j'ai pas envie de m'infliger ça et puis
bah on va essayer alors qu'est ce qu'on
va essayer est ce qu'on va essayer de
débloquer un par un les arguments je ne
sais pas honnêtement je ne sais pas
exactement enfin j'ai une petite idée de
ce à quoi m'attendre
on verra comment on aborde la chose est
ce qu'on considère que le monsieur est
de bonne foi
ça m'étonnerait c'est le monsieur kurt
wiseler et réellement docteur ça
m'étonnerait que ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
soient de bonne foi mais bon j'ai même
pas envie de google et son nom en fait
car toi je suis sûr que c'est non non
non non non je n'avais pas google y sont
on va éviter l'argument d'autorité on va
juste y aller tête baissée on ferme les
yeux comme ça et puis voilà c'est parti
il ya un truc alors preuve que le déluge
de noé a formé les fossiles
il faut il faut quand même rappeler
pourquoi on pense sérieusement que les
fossiles n'ont pas été formés par le
déni de noël je pense que on va
commencer déjà par le début c'est à dire
pourquoi pourquoi ce mec a évidemment
faux voilà on va on va déjà attaqué par
sa est la raison pour laquelle le déluge
de noé nenê n'a certainement pas former
les fossiles c'est tout simplement parce
qu' il existe un nombre n supérieur à 1
paléosols donc à paléosols c'est un seul
fossilisés et souvent on y trouve des
fossiles notamment de racines de plantes
mais aussi de vertébrés et c'est donc à
paléosols c'est un ancien sol qui sait
fossilisé si la théorie du déluge était
vrai il n'existerait qu'un seul
paléosols bay aurait qu'un seul le
déluge doré recouvert tout ce tout le
registre fossile se serait formé dans
ces strates
voilà qui ont été déposées par le déluge
et ensuite il y aurait notre sol à nous
par dessus donc il y aurait qu'un seul
palais au sol et tout le reste du
registre fossile déposé au dessus de se
parler au sol or il existe un nombre n
supérieur à un palais au sol donc si on
prend par exemple les dépôts qui de
spécimens ridge donc spécimens bridge en
amérique spécimens bridge c'est une
forêt pétrifiée
donc vous voyez ici les arbres qui sont
pétrifiés à la verticale avec leurs
racines et ça c'est important ça veut
dire que dans l'est avec les racines il
ya du palais au sol sont pas des arbres
qui se sont déposées à l'horizontale et
puis qui ensuite ont été redressées par
la tectonique non non ce sont des arbres
qui ont été fossilisé en position de vie
et dieu sait que les créationnistes
aiment bien nous nous chatouiller avec
ça je suis sûr que ce sera dans cette
vidéo le coût des arbres déposé en
position en position verticale
je suis sûr que ça vaille et beaux
spécimens bridge et si on demande un cat
way de spécimens bridge voilà ce qu'on
trouve donc voici un cadeau wade
spécimens bridge
quand tu devrait la mettre encore plus
petite
on n'a pas une nation plus grande
non y'a pas écouter ce qu'ont donc quand
on regarde un kata voiliers de spécimens
reach on constate qu'en fait il n'y a
pas qu'un seul niveau avec des arbres
coupés comme ça il y en a en réalité des
dizaines
il y en a 27 il me semble donc là dessus
c'est pas très joli mais c'est pour vous
ayez l'idée a donc spécimens bridge et
c'est une forêt de l'éocène complètement
pétrifié dans une forêt qui avoir 42 50
millions d'années je ne suis pas sûr
exactement mais voilà et donc c'est pas
qu'une forêt en fait il y à 27 forêt ya
27 niveau il ya 27 paléo sol du court 1
parce que chacune de ces forêts à les
racines et tout a donc à 27 paléo sol
donc il faut au moins 27 des bûches pour
expliquer spécimens bridge voilà rien
que ce spécimen ridja parce
qu'évidemment les paléosols y en a pas
qu'en américain il y en a aussi
il y en a aussi partout dans le monde
donc première raison pour laquelle le
déluge n'existe n'a pas formé tout le
registre fossile 1 c'est que il ya plus
de 1 paléosols alors que si on en croit
la théorie du déluge faudrait un seul et
unique paléosols deuxième raison pour
laquelle le déluge ne pas former tous
les fossiles c'est qu'il existe des
dépôts qui ne sont pas marin bah oui
parce que le déluge implique que la mère
a recouvert la totalité des continents
et que donc tous les dépôts à un moment
de l'histoire on était 100% marin or non
tous les dépôts ne sont pas 100 % marin
on a de magnifiques quelqu'un lacustre
vais y compris en france 1 re l'a donc
si je gueule calcaire lacustre eux voilà
donc on a des dépôts purement lacustre
magnifique avec des jolies plein
d'arbres notamment à l'eocène par
exemple donc on a des dépôts la cus avec
de magnifiques planeur mais on ne trouve
rien d'autre qu de fautes qu'une faune
purement d'eau douce dansez dansez
calcaire lacustre les fossiles qu'on
trouve à l'intérieur sont uniquement des
organismes de
comme les planeurs donc ça c'est
inexplicable par le déluge ça il n'y a
aucun moyen qu'un dépôt comme ça se
forme avec le déluge avec le déluge
c'est de la faune marine alors
évidemment tout aurait été mélangés
ensemble évidemment mais du coup on
devrait avoir un mélange là il n'y a pas
de mélanges il ya que de la faune d'eau
douce inexplicable par le déluge aussi
et puis maladroit et puis la troisième
raison pour laquelle le déluge de noé ne
s'est pas produit c'est que le timing
est pas bon le déluge de noé il aurait
quelques milliers d'années
or on a des arbres vivants aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont plus de dix mille ans 1 voilà
donc il me semble qu'il est censé avoir
6000 ans le début de nos vies va
certainement nous rappeler c'est cette
magnifique chronologie cette magnifique
chronologie qui ferait coexistaient ma
grand-mère avec les dinosaures qui est
la chronologie typique des
créationnistes et donc est donc ce ce
déluge de noé serait donc plus jeune que
le plus vieil arbre du monde
c'est dommage pour ce pauvre pauvre
arbres qui donc selon la chronologie de
noé et qui selon la chronologie de ce
monsieur là devraient se trouver des
kilomètres sous terre
enterrée et fossilisés puisque c'est le
registre fossile se seraient formés
ainsi à cause du déluge qui auraient
enterré tout ce qu'il y avait avant donc
bref donc voilà les raisons pour
laquelle le déluge de noël sais c'est
pas un processus géologiques crédible
pour expliquer l'existence du registre
fossile
voilà et puis il ya ça c'est anthony
entre autres entre autres problèmes il
ya aussi le problème vaincu rien est un
événement mondial comme ça ça devrait
avoir laissé une trace plus évidente que
les petits indices là qui va nous
montrer je veux dire vous imaginez bien
qu'un déluge apocalyptique mondiale
faux-pas 1h10 pour pour convaincre les
gens que ça a eu lieu je veux dire
regardez par exemple l'extinction des
dinosaures
la quantité de vidéos de moi de deux
minutes qui disent à regarder
l'extinction des dinosaures
je veux dire c'est un événement
apocalyptique mondiale il suffit d'aller
sur la limite crétacé paléogène est de
montrer la petite couche d'argile noir
voilà et vous avez votre événement
apocalyptique mondiales enregistrées
dans mon registre fossile su fil de fer
voilà il suffit de montrer une photo il
ya celle d'italie qui est très connu il
ya celle en amérique du nord qui est
très connu
il suffit en deux photos que vous avez
démontré qu'il a existé à la belle
époque
un événement apocalyptique mondiale là
il va passer une heure dix à nous à nous
distiller je suis sur des petits détails
de merde qui vont te faire dire ah ouais
ce n'est pas complètement con mais voilà
non ça veut dire l'existence d'un
événement apocalyptique mondiale devrait
être plus évidente que toutes les
preuves
preuve qu'il va nous montrer pendant
cette vidéo
preuve est au singulier d'ailleurs
j'aimerais pas noté mais encore le titre
preuve est au singulier donc 1h10 c'est
une preuve voilà ensuite et ensuite il
ya une très très bonne raison pour
laquelle on pense que le déluge de
données n'a pas eu lieu c'est une région
c'est une raison qui était extrêmement
connu en réalité quand on y pense
pourquoi aucun calendrier ne démarre à
l'époque de la fin du déluge aucun
calendrier moderne ou antiques n'a pris
la fin du déluge comme débuts comme
début c'est à dire qu'on aime encore une
fois c'est un événement mondial
c'est un événement qui a marqué
l'histoire de l'humanité tout entière je
veux dire l'humanité toute entière a
failli s'éteindre à part la petite
famille de noé
je dirais l'humanité était là pour
l'heure pour le savoir pour enregistrer
de cet événement
donc normalement il devrait y avoir au
moins un calendrier qui démarre il ya
6000 ans vous connaissez un calendrier
qu'ils aient marre
à la fin du déluge aucun des calendriers
mayas aztèques
tous les calendriers antique qu'ils
soient chinois ou la porte
n'importe quelle civilisation de
mésopotamie égyptien tout ça aucun
calendrier ne démarre à la fin du début
pourquoi alors il existe effectivement
la possibilité que ce soit une
coïncidence que les gens aient oublié
que les gens aient trouvé qu'il ya eu
des événements plus importants que ça
qu'ils se soient passées après nous
important que la fin du monde je sais
pas mais pourquoi pas ou alors il est
possible que cet événement n'est jamais
eu lieu bref donc non processus le
déluge de noé en tant que phénomène
historique insiste genesis eastwood ou
géologiques ça casse pas des briques
voilà et ça c'est à peu près les raisons
les plus évidentes pour laquelle ça
casse pas des briques il y en a il en
existe une infinité le dire mais bref
continueront d écriture pourtant lorsque
nous regardons si sexy sur nous trouvons
très peu de choses explicite dans la
bible sur les personnes et leur
formation
c'est dommage c'est dommage quand même
que la vie mais ne lis pas comment se
sont formés des fossiles aux lectures et
elles se trouvent les fossiles ils ont
été formés par dieu pour qu'on croie en
évolution ce serait quand même marrant
que dieu veulent de nous qu'on croit
l'évolution est en fait les
créationnistes du coup se croit plus
malin que dieu est là tu te croirais les
créationnistes se croit plus malin que
dieu parce que dieu a créé les fossiles
pour contrôler l'évolution
donc est ce que dans un sens je ne suis
pas un meilleur chrétiens en croyant
l'évolution qu'en croyant en la création
donc
sa part d'une grande foule déjà on
commence par une analyse en profondeur
la vie mais évidemment la bible qui ne
donne aucun phénomène intéressant a
expliqué réellement vélo alors rappelle
rappelle intéressant ici le déluge a tué
tous les animaux terrestres
1 donc les dauphins apparemment dieu
préfère les dauphins dieu tu les hommes
mais ne tue pas les dauphins les
dauphins évidemment à chaque fois
vérifier que les bêtises qu'on dit son
temps sont bien alignées avec les
bêtises qui sont dit dans la bible
la bible est évidemment un livre de
science a sérieusement
bref oui donc le déluge n'a pas tué les
dauphins donc la bible dit bien que
c'est tous les animaux terrestres qui
ont morflé pendant les luges ce qui vous
fait nous demander pourquoi il y aurait
des fossiles de dauphin du coup parce
qu'il y en a dans la formation pisco si
on va chercher formation pisco puisqu'au
formation'' très connu pour son registre
fossile de cétacés et de cétacés en tout
genre c'est magnifique magnifique crâne
ici de baleines voilà ici une mandibule
de quelque chose qui a l'air d'être un
cachalot fossile
voilà
n'a regardé magnifique fossiles de
baleine de la formation pisco vous avez
de la balle et des baleines en egypte
qui paraît à des magnifiques fossiles
voilà de cétacés basile aux ohrid et
donc pourquoi les baleines aurait
morfler du coup pendant le déluge
si ça n'a tué que les animaux terrestres
vous avez deux heures un puits sans
compter les foraminifères à je veux dire
les peaux foraminifères envoyer des
énormes
il faudra bini faire tout l'élu machel
c'est à dire toutes les accumulations de
coquillages de coquillages mort c'est
pareil c'est lui aussi qui les a formés
ils ne vous le dira pas parce qu'il va
certainement essayé d'esquiver tout ce
qui est faux de marine tu vois là je
peux déjà faire des prédictions sur un
ovale et son truc là il va certainement
essayer dé ce qui lui est tout ce qui
est faux de marine
sauf les faune marine
tout va être cohérent avec la bible la
sauvent défaut de marianne que vous
allez voir
alors est-ce que les fossiles ont été
créés par dieu dès le départ c'est bien
c'est bien en plus il nous explique
pourquoi du coup c'est très très
improbable qu'est ce que la bible dit
est vrai parce que si la bicis que
l'adie bible dit est vrai alors dieu a
créé la mort avant de créer la mort
c'est de mal
les la mort n'a été techniquement la
mort n'a pas été inventé tout de suite
si on en croit la bible donc les
fossiles sont une preuve de mort donc ce
que dit la bible n'est pas vrai c'est
bien c'est bien mais je suis sûr que
c'est pas vraiment la direction qui va
prendre
admirez quand même le l'arrière-plan
c'est à dire qu'elle s'est quand même
nuit dans un laboratoire pour faire
croire que c'était une chaleur ça veut
dire le mec le mec est censé faire un
exposé de géologie et il s'est dit dans
la droite dans un laboratoire de chimie
pour faire son truc c'est genre on va
faire croire que c'est l'assurance
c'est tout juste si la rose il est trés
bonne explication de ce que la cause des
35 heures tu sers avec un métis des
pieds qu'on fait les utiliser dès le
mettre à peu près d'accord samedi dans
cinq ans brillant trouve pas trop de de
maquereaux france à part sur la fin ce
qui est d'ailleurs ce qui est d'ailleurs
une des preuves de l'évolution je veux
dire c'est que l'on trouve pas de preuve
de vie organisée avant les premiers
fossiles sont des bactéries les
des cyanobactéries les stromatolithes et
puis on commence à trouver des formes de
vie organisé et puis on commence à
trouver des formes de vie avec des
squelettes à partir du cambrien et puis
on commence à trouver une abondance de
vertébrés à partir du silurien même déjà
en dans leurs devis sien on a des
vertébrés mais manquant brière m'a dit
non on n'a pas encore de cambrai de
vertébrés au cambrien en tout cas pas
dans la faune de burgès ni de shenyang
mais bref on commence à trouver une
abondance de vertébrés qu'à partir du
silurien et au dévonien c'est vraiment
là où on a les poissons et puis à partir
de la fin du dévonien on commence à
trouver des vertébrés terrestres
donc il ya une certaine organisation qui
reflète l'évolution dans le registre
fossile donc ça c'est plutôt une preuve
pour l'évolution et pas le contraire
jusque là je veux plutôt d'accord avec
lui c'est simplifier effectivement mais
on peut rappeler non plus il estime pas
les organismes en larmes je viens voir
comment il va se dépatouiller avec ce
sont des animaux qui se sont normalement
pas affectés par le daemon ces
organismes marins ou relativement alors
je n'ont apparemment lui pour lui une
mégafaune cambrienne bon alors je veux
bien croire que la
que la mégafaune marine cambrienne est
suffisamment différentes du reste du
paléozoïque pour en faire une méga faune
à séparer le reste du paléozoïque
pourquoi pas mais alors unifiée celle du
mésozoïque et du cénozoïque faut quand
même avoir faut quand même avoir les
pieds charger un sco mésozoïque on a
quand même les ammonites les
plésiosaures des ichtyosaures qui sont
qui font partie de la mégafaune marine
très très très différente de ce qu'on
trouve dans les océans du cénozoïque a
quand même où il y en a pas et oui qui
sont dominés par les cétacés et et pas
les ammonites donc bon la chose
principale que les faunes que les
méga-feux de marine du cénozoïque et du
mésozoïque ont en commun c'est la
domination des bivalves ça la dominance
des bivalves et l'absence relative de
daikin au derme dans les pas des kilos
d'herbe de cris no id dans l'est dans
les assemblages de faune peu profondes
mais bon voilà quoi puis l'absence de
l'épi l'absence de trilobites l'absence
de trilobites bon bref
bizarre quand même cette idée de vouloir
unifier le le semnoz oic avec le
mésozoïque mais bon je me demande où
vivre avec ça je continue de penser vont
être les principales focus de sa
présentation
je ne sais pas quel est son public de
base mais enfin le live ya quand même de
blast et paléozoïque cénozoïque prix
gaïa sans jamais expliquer ces termes là
je ne sais pas si le monsieur
essaye d'établir le fait qu' il est
clair c'est un expert dans ce qu'il
prône anti qu'il croit être un expert
fois qu'il essaye de poser les coudes
sur la table là pour dire que c'est moi
le patron c'est moi qui sais tu vois
c'est pas toi donc là c'est intéressant
ce qui vient de dire il vient de parler
de cuisine gleam danse au sol des
fossiles de plus en plus modernes dans
la bouche d'un créationnisme da
créationnistes entendre parler de
fossiles de plus en plus modernes au
travers du sens je sais pas si vous
voyez à peu près où est la dissonance
mais il ya une grosse grosse grosse
dissonances donc mais pour l'instant
pour l'instant c'est parce qu'ici
créationnistes que ça ce qu'il dit alors
cependant pour que les créations sont
fans de cette présentation stratigraphie
principe que j'explique cours mais
étudiants je pense que l'idée en fait se
présenter comme en est la science de
façon la plus brutale possible pour
ensuite la faire contraster avec
l'interprétation très simpliste et
créationnistes
je pose comme ça mais ces prédictions
sur la table si on verra bien vous
laisse lire les sous titres j'ai pas
envie de dire toi un sushi trois
familles des grenouilles sétois
exactement celle dont on a de meilleurs
registre aussi drôle de ça y est le
déluge pardon tu peux répéter ça te
plaît explique le sénat se fixer après
dans son petit délire personnel le cndd
aux os x et après le déluge et le
précambrien c'est avant le déni et pour
lui neuf bleus pour lui le déluge a lieu
entre une et dix selon lui le déluge a
duré cinq cents millions du coup il va
il va aller vous dire que la prône au
logis de des lieux n'est pas dans le
sahel dans quelques milliards d'années
se serait bien ce serait bien mais alors
arriver à nous expliquer que le
paléozoïque et le mésozoïque sont en
fait où les résultats d'un seul
événement
catastrophique sous on parle quand même
je kilomètres de sédiments tempête que
les alpes à l'himalaya tous assez formés
par défaut si l'essentiel du mésozoïque
ça des roches du mézenc la console de
kilomètres de cette menace
mais bien évidemment ne prend pas des
rushes il ne parle que des fossiles
soyouz juste vous convaincre que les
fossiles sont été formés par le nes mais
que pareil il va certainement là il a
esquivé la question de l'épaisseur des
sédiments de façon magistrale intérêts
non alors les fossiles donc parce que ce
qu'il est en train de nous dire c'est
que les fossiles du mésozoïque et du
paléozoïque sont des faux cils qui sont
relativement communs et bien préservés
alors ce qu'on vous montre à la télé
dans les journaux dans les reportages
oui évidemment ils sont communs et bien
préservé puisque sinon on voulait
montrerez pas tous les fossiles
dégueulasse qu'on trouve on vous les
montre pas mais la quantité de faux cils
dégueulasse on trouve dans cette
dans cet intervalle elle est gigantesque
c'est juste qu'on va pas vous la montrer
parce que c'est pas beau c'est pas joli
à voir
ça fait pas des belles images ça fait
pas des belles photos donc le dire ce
n'est pas un appel aux complots là que
je suis en train de faire c'est un appel
à la logique là on va pas vous montrer
des fossiles dégueulasse c'est normal
donc non non non non cette partie du
registre fossile n'allait pas forcément
mieux préservés que le reste c'est juste
que les fossiles qu'on vous en montre
wii sont mieux préservés que le ray
parce que sinon vous les montrerai pas
on a honte de montrer les fossiles qui
sont dégueulasses et du coup ça veut
dire aussi que cette partie du registre
fossile est mieux préservé que les
fossiles du cénozoïque ce qui est faux
ce qui est complètement faux je veux
dire aller voir mes selles voilà donc
typique typique cénozoïque mais celle
donc le dépôt de mais celle des pions
rajouter fossiles derrière juste pour
être sûr voilà regarder la qualité de
préservation des fossiles de messel
squelette articulé avec avec magnifique
magnifique préservation de tissus mous
non le cénozoïque il a énormément de
sites ou qui sont extrêmement bien où
les fossiles sont extrêmement bien
préservés ça c'est que mécène mais enfin
si on vous montre par exemple la tenez
prenons en france mona voilà les
fossiles de mena dans l'aveyron alors
nos veines pardon maintenant non pas
maintenant même la mena voilà donc la
fosse il demeura voyez magnifique
poisson complètement articulé pareil
présentation de préservation de tissus
mous des insectes il ya le primate de
mena ménanteau terium ménages terium
est-ce qu'on me voir mais ne therion là
le voilà donc la basse à des tiers c'est
l'image de retraite de science c'est
nous qu'on a fait donc mes nato terium
c'est un primate est comparé à un
fossile de mécènes voilà ménanteau
therion vous avez le crade tissus mous
préservé que squelette complet bref la
totale quoi
un total donc mont à leux cénozoïque du
coup enfin la prédiction qu'il fait là
qui est que les fossiles sont mieux
préservés au paléozoïque et au
mésozoïque comparé aux cénozoïque c'est
faux c'est faux ou alors la prédiction
là c'est que grâce au déluge il ya une
meilleure préservation alors le déluge
je rappelle comme il l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est un événement
catastrophique
un événement catastrophique c'est pas
gagné d'avancé que la préservation sera
meilleur pendant un événement
catastrophique a au contraire pendant un
événement catastrophique
on s'attend à quoi
à la déposition de gros blocs de gros
fragments on s'attend à la déposition du
coût de ce qu'on appelle un pli d'agde
c'est à dire alors c'est pas si je vais
arriver à trouver ça sent mauvais sur de
la pâtisserie mais bref si vous regardez
ça marche très bien d'un coup dingue
c'est ça donc quand il ya des gros
mouvements d'eau donc par exemple
pendant un déluge quand il ya des gros
mouvements d'aubin il ya des gros blocs
qui sont charriées en plus des petits en
plus du sable donc quand vous avez des
gros blocs qui sont charriées bas vous
avez formation de poudingue et ses
poulains
c'est une catastrophe pour la
préservation de fossiles bat déjà c'est
un choix vous imaginez bien que des gros
blocs comme ça qui sont secoués comme sa
part des grosses masses d'eau salée
c'est un hachoir à tout ce qui passe
devant à tous finir en miettes et danser
poudingue c'est quand même assez rare de
trouver les mots fossiles là vous voyez
on a des poux dingue de grosse épaisseur
est pareil c'est comme les paliers au
sol
il existe n supérieur à 1 poudingue dans
le monde donc
donc c'est pareil le rien qu'ici là où
j'habite à johannesbourg on a au moins
la succession de cinq ou six poudingue
dans la formation du vide 20h30 c'est là
où on trouve leurs dons qu'ils sont bien
cartographier ces poux d'un gars c'est
là où il y alors danser poudingue parce
que ce sont des dépôts où il ya eu
beaucoup d'érosion et donc les
particules d'or ont été emmenés par
l'érosion danser poudingue bombe à ces
essais poudingue dont on trouve aussi
des diamants d'ailleurs souvent dans les
puddings donc on connaît bien les poux
d'agde et il existe beaucoup de
poudingue c'est un bon mot poudingue
j'aime bien dire poudingue poudingue
je deviens poudingue voilà un bon bref
donc donc donc donc non c'est pas gagné
d'avancé que la préservation sera
meilleure dans un événement de haute et
dans un dépôt de haute énergie on
appelle ça un dépôt de haute énergie
au contraire il faut de la basse énergie
pour la bonne préservation donc ce qu'on
appelle par exemple les calcaires
lithographique un petit calcaire
lithographique lithographique qu'un
petit calcaire lithographique saha
sédiments pourriez très très très très
très faim voilà qui s'est formée dans un
lagon donc à l'abri des vagues
et là vous avez de la bonne préservation
regardez-moi ça regardez comme c'est
beau [ __ ] donc ça c'est assez rhin
dans les alpes en france magnifique
petit reptile vous avez quelqu'un
lithographies de bavière de partir des
calcaires lithographique demande pierre
indirectement taper ça en f1 peut pas
arrêter de se mentir des directement
taper saulnot alors je ne sais plus
écrire sur le nous fait je sais plus où
elle loge dans sur le fun solo feu bah
non je ne sais plus mais l'âge de cent
de nos fans mais sans nos fans c'est
aussi un calcaire lithographique
d'envoyer magnifique y habiter rose or
un magnifique crevettes magnifique
archéoptéryx quand même tu tapes soldes
fn et tu trouves parquet au tennis j'ai
vraiment dû écrire ça ne fait pas comme
il faut arqués harkat et aux uns et aux
terribles a donc archéoptéryx spécimens
de berlin voit là par exemple ça
ces spécimens de berlin parce qu'il est
à berlin au musée de berlin
mais sinon ce spécimen il a été trouvé à
sun fan c'est pareil là vous avez le
musée londres le spécimen de londres qui
avait aussi été trouvée la salle des
fêtes tous ont été trouvés à peine de
toute façon c'est du calcaire
lithographique qui permet la
préservation la préservation des tissus
mous comme ça idem tout ce qui est
dinosaures à plumes de chine
ça a aussi été préservés dans un niveau
de basse énergie dans un sédiment très
fin mais là c'était la cendre volcanique
donc non les milieux de haute énergie ne
favorise pas une bonne une bonne
préservation et j'ai presque envie de
dire au contraire et donc
pareil la prédiction du genre de
préservation que provoquerait un déluge
universel c'est plutôt la formation d'un
gros plus dingues bien fat
oui qu'on ne trouve nulle part
curieusement donc formation d'un énorme
poudingue bien fat qui seraient
globalement plein de petits fragments
d'organismes voyez des coquilles broyer
des coquilles broyer des ossements
broyer des morceaux de plantes broyer
mais qui globalement préserverait pas de
très beaux fossiles contrairement à ce
qu'il est en train de dire je m'inscris
en faux quand à cette affirmation c'est
très facile de produire un fossile
vous avez les fossiles les fontaines
pétrifiantes dans les alpes par exemple
donc je tape fontaines pétrifiantes
voilà donc battre les magnifiques celle
du réotier là je suis allé la voir la
fontaine pétrifiante durée authier avec
la fontaine pétrifiante durée routier
elle se forme pas des fontaines il ya de
la vie autour c'est une fontaine ya de
l'eau donc s'il ya de l'eau il ya de la
vie il ya des failles notamment qui
tombent dans l'eau est comme l'eau est
chargé de quelqu'un en fait le calcaire
se dépose sur les feuilles et forment
des fossiles
donc les feuilles sont pas pétrifié mais
si vous voulez elles sont incrustés
elles sont en croûte et et la feuille se
décompose mais par contre la croûte elle
elle reste et à la forme de la feuille
ça forme un fossile et après il suffit
que là qu'une nouvelle cristallisation
se forment à l'intérieur du moule de la
feuille pour former le fossile de la
feuille en question donc la
fossilisation c'est un processus qui
peut aller très très vite si vous êtes
dans un environnement qui y est
favorable
et c'est quelque chose que les géologues
admettre tout à fait à ne dire faux pas
j'espérais que il y aurait les photos
justement de des fossiles en train de se
former à la fontaine du réotier parce
qu'on les voit quand on va visiter la
fontaine durable
elles sont par terre on voit les
feuilles en train de se faire entre
côtés et vous avez même des escargots et
vous avez dans les tourbières aussi des
tourbières c'est un endroit où les
choses se préserve très facilement
c'est pareil vous avez des choses qui
sont déjà super fossil qui ont à peine
dix mille ans dans les tourbières et qui
sont déjà subi fossilisés c'est à dire
qu'ils sont déjà en processus de
fossilisation en train de se transformer
en roche chimiquement le dire en train
de se transformer en roche donc non le
processus de fossilisation nez ne
n'implique pas forcément des temps très
très long c'est pas vrai et dans une
grotte par exemple c'est pareil dans une
grotte si vous avez un
si vous avez un crâne qui se retrouve un
crâne peut se retrouver très facilement
emprisonné dans les calcaires d une
grotte pour peu qu'il y ait de l'eau qui
coule dessus ça va ça va rapidement se
retrouver enfermé dans une stalactite ou
une stalagmite plutôt une stalagmite
d'ailleurs parce que une stalactite ça
voudrait dire que le crâne et au plafond
les spéléos thèmes comme on les appelle
ça les concrétions ça peut être formé
très rapidement des fossiles et c'est
pas spécialement rares jeux qui elle
m'aura rossi s'est pas spécialement rare
le processus de fossilisation est pas
particulièrement rare c'est parce que
nous en tant que animaux terrestres
on n'a pas l'habitude de voir des
fossiles le milieu terrestre est un
milieu essentiellement érosif donc c'est
un milieu où il ya surtout de l'érosion
qui a lieu donc en tant qu'animaux
terrestre on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
des choses se déposer dans des
environnements très fossilifère mais par
contre si vous étiez un animal marin
vous verriez des choses se faire
enterrer hyper rapidement sous des
tonnes de sédiments de façon quotidienne
j'ai envie de dire donc non c'est la
seule raison pour laquelle nous êtres
humains considérons intuitivement la
fossilisation comme un phénomène rare
comme un phénomène rare c'est parce qu
on vit dans un environnement aérien donc
principalement érosif voilà c'est juste
ça si vous étiez un poisson se serait
papa
[Musique]
ça fait dix minutes qu'il est en train
de parler pour l'instant il n'a rien dit
de très controversés ou très intéressant
voilà pour l'instant je fais attention
restera relativement basse je ne sais
pas ce que les créationnistes apprécié
tant dans cette présentation il même
parce qu'il est si intéressante pour
l'instant enfin mme gillard des
premières minutes sont pour ça qu'on
retrouve surtout des coquilles et des
squelettes
le fait est que dieu a créé les uns
c'est là tu vois quand même les normes
conflits d'intérêts qu'il y a dans sa
tête de base c'est que le fait est que
dieu les dieux l effet dieu et les faits
ça ce mix assez difficilement enfin de
le dire pour quelqu'un qui se fait
passer pour un docteur l'a peut-être
docteur en théologie mais j'ai dit je
veux pas aller vérifier son profil pas
l'argument d'autorité mais
le fait est que dieu a créé les
organismes à temps alors je rappelle je
rappelle quand même que l'une des
premières choses qu'il a dit c'est que
le problème des faux cils et que c'est
c'est que les fossiles admettent le gros
problème qu'il a avec les fossiles et le
fait que dieu ait pu créer les fossiles
enfin l'idée que dieu ait pu créer les
fossiles c'est que ça voudrait dire que
dieu avait l'idée de la mort avant que
la mort soit inventé encore une fois en
suivant les écritures bibliques
donc dieu et a eu l'idée de la mort
avant que la mort sont inventés donc du
coup les fossiles peuvent pas avoir été
formé par dieu à la création donc les
fossiles ont forcément été formé après
pendant le déluge ça c'est sa logique à
lui d'après ce que j'ai compris
par contre dieu ça l'a pas emmerdé de
créer des scavengers enfin des ducs ou
des charognards a dit manger quoi les
charognards avant qu'il invente la mort
du coup vous allez me dire que la hyène
avec ses grosses dents broyeur dos elle
manger des pommes
maintenant on n'a pas le droit de manger
des pommes dans le jardin d'éden
bon je tiens juste à souligner le fait
que le ver est le vrai que le concept de
charognards est à peu près aussi
problématique que concept de le fossile
c'est juste ça c'est le concept de
charognards est d'avoir créé de tous les
animaux avant d'avoir créé la mort est
exactement le même problème que celui de
la création des fossiles avant de avant
d'avoir créé la mort c'est à dire que tu
admet l'existence de la mort avant que
la mort existe donc l'existence même des
charognards est autant un problème que
l'existence des faux cils est ce que ça
veut dire que les charognards ont été
créés pendant le déluge point
d'interrogation
et comme j'ai dit c'est pas si difficile
dans les océans les cds
les décomposeurs si on admet que dieu a
créé les bactéries les composent heures
avant la mort c'est pareil ça pose
autant de problèmes que les faux sushis
braila je sais pas trop où il va avec
cette explication à ce qu'il essaye de
nous est ce qu'il essaye de nous dire ce
que le processus de fossilisation est
une impossibilité statistiques en fait
là je suis un peu des côtes menacées
parce que jusqu'à présent et quand je
les dis il n'a pas dit ce qui fait que
ça mais du coup je vois pas où je veux
en venir c'est à dire que pour l'instant
il n'a montré aucune preuve que le
déluge de doré à faire le registre
fossile
il a juste dit il a juste dit que
possiblement déluge de noé a eu lieu
quelque part entre le paléozoïque fc
méric alors c'est ce qui va ce qui cause
ledit qudra secret juste 500 millions
d'années d'existence de la vie mais nous
explique le concept de créolisation et à
quel point c'est un miracle si la
fossilisation henin registre fossile que
parce que il a existé suffisamment
d'animaux et de plantes et de
l'organisme par le passé pour que
statistiquement il y en ait au moins
quelqu'un qui se creuse il m'a tellement
un miracle on va éviter d'employer un
miracle c'est juste effectivement être
fossilisés éphémère probabilité
statistique mais il ya tellement aux
organismes qui vivent des heures sur
cère tout le temps à toutes les époques
que du coup ça finit par arriver quand
même j'ai envie de dire que c'est
presque une stratégie créationnistes
assez classique de noyer le poisson
comme ça
c'est à dire j'ai fait un peu fou tube
doigts j'ai l'impression ils essaient de
nous dire que ce paléontologue pense que
la fossilisation a lieu d'une façon qui
est très hautement improbable à ce que
ses sens et du coup il va nous expliquer
dans la foule est ce que je voyais alors
que le délit d' ouvrir lui explique
vachement mieux que les que les fois ci
on se forme et comme j'ai dit les
fossiles ça peut se former très
facilement battu par exemple cette
dernière phase là il s'implique tout
autant aux fossiles français durant le
déluge j'aille à une toute une partie de
son isolement qui s'applique tout autant
à la formation des profils s'il avait
été formé par la lune sans ça on évacue
ça donc je pense oui mais voilà c'est ça
exactement le fait est que dans le monde
actuel la fossilisation est un processus
rares voilà alors et ça je pense que
tout le monde est d'accord pour le dire
que la france que la fossilisation est
un processus rare mais encore une fois
il existe des millions d'espèces
vivantes
je dis bien des espèces un des millions
d'espèces vivantes chacune représentée
par bon peut-être moins chacune mais en
tout cas la plupart d'entre elles
représentées par des millions voire des
milliards par exemple homo sapiens
d'individus même un processus
extrêmement rare ah c'est quasiment
inévitable si vous voulez que ce
processus extrêmement rare se produise
voilà c'est juste quand vous multipliez
les probabilités par des milliards même
la probabilité la plus infime devient
inévitable et bon bref c'est juste ça et
comme je les dis le fait est que la
fossilisation n'est pas
si rare que ça au final c'est juste les
environnements propices à la
fossilisation ne sont pas ceux auxquels
nous en tant qu'êtres humains nous
sommes familiers mais encore une fois
vivre dans l'océan par exemple il ya
beaucoup de milieux qui sont très
propices à la fossilisation dans les
océans
donc je sais pas si c'est vraiment là
qu'il a envie d'aller là le monsieur là
allez nous dire que la fossilisation
c'est trop c'est trop compliqué pour
avoir lieu alors du coup c'est dieu qui
du coup c'est le déluge le déluge est un
meilleur moyen d'expliquer la
fossilisation je ne pense pas j'espère
que non parce que comme je les dis le
déluge est un ton contraire un moyen
tout à fait kata de faire de la
fossilisation le déluge s'il a eu lieu
c'était un gros broyeur à ordures qui a
tout défoncer à gros coups de de roches
qui ont été obligés par des masses
phénoménales d'eau donc bon
voilà j'espère que c'est pas par là qui
va parce que la vidéo va être courte
encore une fois donc bien préservés jeu
non j'ai déjà dit pourquoi bien préservé
il faut pas trop insister là dessus les
fossiles sont très communs non pas tant
que ça va je veux dire combien combien
d'entre vous peuvent se targuer d'avoir
trouver des fossiles
enfin combien d'entre vous peuvent se
targuer de trouver des fossiles tous les
jours en allant au boulot
d'ailleurs les fossiles c'est pas si
commun que ça veut dire qu'on va voir
s'il ya bien une chose qu'on sait à
propos des fossiles c'est qu'il faut
avoir l'oeil pour les trouver un intrant
cas au bout d'un moment faut faut aussi
faut aussi faut aussi admettre les
choses telles qu'elles sont ils sont pas
si commun que ça les fossiles après vous
avez des roches dans lesquelles les
fossiles sont très communs comme par
exemple les lumas shell voulait
les endroits où tout l'écho qui se sont
accumulés les unes sur les autres et
c'est l'accumulation des coquilles qui a
formé la roche l'a éventuellement mais
on parle de fossiles qu'ils sont petits
relativement petit dans ce cas là pas de
mégaphones comme il a parlé tout à
l'heure mais bon bref c'est juste là
ouais je crois qu'il va vraiment dans
cette direction ou pour nous expliquer
que c'est le déluge de noé qui est
forcément le responsable de la formation
des fossiles
donc on est face à quelqu'un qui va
littéralement fichiers sur le principe
d' actualise mme on sait exactement
comment se forment les fossiles
puisqu'on voit les phénomènes se
produire aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle
on voit les tourbières se forme et on
voit les les organismes se faire
recouvrir par du sable dans les océans
on voit les on voit les tourbillons pas
les tourbières et les lacs de comment ça
s'appelle des bitumes aussi les
organismes se coincer dans des trucs de
bitume on voyait encore là je parle
surtout des trucs terrestre mais dans
l'eau c'est pareil il ya tellement dans
les océans il ya tellement d'endroits où
tu peut former des fossiles je veux dire
et les zones peu profondes ça n'arrête
pas dès que vous avez je veux dire il
suffit de vous balader sur la plage à
marée basse vous allez voir les
accumulations de coquillages vous allez
voir des aussi des le sable qui ceinture
parce qu'évidemment le sable qui à la
surface il est mou mais après dés que
vous creusez un petit peu le sable il
est super dur en dessous mais il est
déjà c'est déjà en train de se
fossiliser et ce sable il est plein
d'organismes il est plein de coquillages
il est plein de foraminifères il est
plein de
il est plein de coquilles de trucs qui
sont en train de se fossiliser avec donc
je veux dire tout ça les géologues l'on
observé donc pour pour aller vers la
conclusion que le déluge de noé c'est le
seul moyen d'expliquer l'existence des
faux cils faut quand même chier sur le
principe d' actualiser je veux dire si
vous avez un très bon moyen d'expliquer
les choses avec les processus qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui est qu'on est
capable
d'observer aujourd'hui pourquoi aller
chercher un événement surnaturel
catastrophique
j'ai seulement si vous partez du
principe que qu'un enterrement rapide
est une condition nécessaire au la
fossilisation c'est pas le cas c'est pas
le cas je même pouvoir vous montrer
justement des petits fossiles qui montre
que ça ne peut pas fonctionner comme ça
par exemple si vous regardez ici
cette image ici vous avez alors je suis
pas sûr de ce que c'est que la dent à
droite par contre 7 dans la gauche là
c'est une dent d'éléphant moderne c'est
une dent de d'éléphants d'afrique
moderne on reconnaît bien ici les gros
l'ofs typique des éléphants d'afrique
moderne je pense que ça doit être une
norme de la fantasy ou peut-être demain
mais je suis patient
le principe étant si vous regardez cette
bande éléphants d'afrique on reconnaît
que c'est une dent qui est resté très
très longtemps à la surface et a
complètement séché parce qu'elle est
tout craque les voyez c'est que toutes
ces craquelures là c'est dû au fait que
cette dent est restée à la surface et à
sécher et du coup elle a commencé le les
protéines à l'intérieur de la dent qui
lui donnait sa cohésion se sont se sont
asséchés du coup elle a commencé à
devenir crack très fragile et craquante
craquante et les craquantes cette petite
bref vous voyez l'idée donc il suffirait
de trouver dans le registre fossile à
l'intérieur de la roche a donc pas à la
surface sur le nouveau sol après le
déluge 90 à l'intérieur de la roche
formé par le déluge il suffirait de
trouver ne serait-ce qu'un seul faux
cils de dents de mammouth craquer de
cette façon pour démontrer que le déluge
n'a pas eu lieu puisque le déluge par
définition il ya plein d'eau partout
donc les fossiles ne peuvent pas
et chez à la surface n'est ce pas n'est
ce pas n'est ce pas pour bah merde
une bande mammouth la ccar nagui
nationaliste u muséum a donc on peut le
dire on peut rien dire donc bref
nouveaux fossiles dans la collection une
nouvelle dents de mammouth et regardez
ces belles craquelures sept belles dents
de mammouth qui est bien restée à la
surface a bien séché avant de se
fossiliser donc n'a jamais connu le
déluge
voilà ce qu on a oublié de dire à ce
moment qu'il aurait dû se noyer je
suppose ça doit être ça le problème dans
et puis c'est pas les seuls évidemment
là je vous en montre qu'une mais il y en
a plein voyez là c'est défense voyez là
c'est l'ong craquelures longitudinal
c'est typiquement de l'ivoire qui a
séché à la surface qui du coup ça a
cassé le long de la fibre quoi donc ça
c'est très typique des dents de mammouth
d c'est très typique des fossiles pardon
qui ont séché à la surface avant d'être
enterré et puis évidemment il n'ya pas
que les mammouths moi même quand je vais
à la recherche de fossiles dans le karoo
quasiment tous les fossiles qu'on trouve
ils ont la surface complètement craquelé
très très typique parce que ça marche
aussi sur les eaux impact sur les dents
les dents ça se voit beaucoup plus parce
que les maïs est très très cassant une
fois que c'est sec mais ça marche aussi
sur les os les eaux voilà si vous
marquez drive bonne par exemple noski ce
krach de plus en plus parce qu'il se
sèche et ce à des fossiles comme ça
enfin des fossiles qu'ils ont c'est
peut-être là voyez qu'ils sont qui sont
séchées qui commencerait et dont on voit
que le losc a été exposé au soleil parce
que ça c'est des craquelures qui sont
essentiellement dus et le soleil dont on
voit que les ont été exposés au soleil
pendant une longue période avant d'avoir
été enterré ça ça se trouve ça se trouve
tout le temps en tout cas dans le karoo
on a quasiment que ça des eaux qui ont
été d'abord exposé très longtemps au
soleil avant d'être enterré
très bon exemple la voyez comme il est
sec et cassé déminéralisée et tout voilà
ça c'est très typique des fossiles qu'on
trouve des fossiles qu'on trouve dans le
cadre par exemple dans le carrousel des
tpo continentaux c'est des endroits où
les eaux ont d'abord été exposé à l'air
libre et au soleil avant d'être enterré
donc tous ces eaux là il va falloir leur
expliquer qu'ils ont raté le coche que
le déluge normalement il n'aurait pas dû
avoir le temps de sécher et c'est pour
ça que je dis là c'est très important
quand il dit ah ils sont très très bien
préservés oui mais c'est pas si c'est
seulement ce qu'on vous montre qu'ils
sont très très bien préservé les autres
ils sont comme ça les autres ils font
cette gueule là la voilà donc oui ça a
l'air d'être important c'est pas c'est
peut-être un détail pour vous mais pour
nous ça veut dire beaucoup
donc non tous les fossiles ne sont pas
bien préservés et justement leur
préservation pour certains et est le
signe qu'ils n'ont pas été enterrés
immédiatement qu'ils ont été exposés au
soleil et qu'ils ont commencé à sécher
et ce cas c est donc le lanternon là il
parle de rapine burial donc
l'enterrement rapide l'enterrement
rapide n'est pas une condition
nécessaire à la facilitation un héros
s'il peut rester un an deux ans dans la
surface avant d'être enterré surtout
dans les grottes d'ailleurs surtout dans
les systèmes de grottes dans les
systèmes de grottes en fait c'est des
pièges à fossiles les grottes et donc
vous avez les inondations qui vont
ramener les fossiles dans les trous dans
les arènes enfin le palais fossiles
justement ils vont ramener les restes
d'organismes qui sont à la surface dans
les troubles et ils ont ces organismes
ils n'ont pas à être ferait forcément
ils peuvent avoir passé plusieurs années
déjà allé en libres 1 vous avez des
coquilles de mollusques que vous pouvez
avoir des vous pouvez avoir des eaux qui
ont passé un an deux ans dix ans à la
surface avant d'être enterré info si un
homme peut avoir passé dix ans à la
surface il était pas trop exposer au
soleil
s'ils étaient exposées au soleil au bout
de trois ans il finit en poussière mais
le dire il ya quand même une et un
espace entre 0 et 3 ans
où il peut encore être enterrée et finir
fossilisés donc une un enterrement
rapide n'est pas une condition
strictement nécessaire à la
fossilisation so what you
oui mais non alors là son exemple du
corail en plus il l'a très très très
très mal choisi parce qu'il ya une
explication très très très très simple
un corail quand il meurt il blanchit et
une fois qu'il est blanchi
qu'est ce qui lui arrive au corail bah
rien il lui arrive rien il est blanc et
puis il reste où il est il a toujours sa
forme de corail il est juste mort on le
sait parce qu'on en a tué plein décors
eux nous autres êtres humains on le sait
on les flingues à tour de bras les
coraux donc il ya des coraux ils sont
comme ça dix vingt trente ans alors
l'érosion finira par les avoir l'érosion
finira par les avoir il y aura peut-être
une tempête à un moment mais imaginez un
corail dans un lagon carbonatées parce
que les coraux il forme des barrières et
les barrières forme des lagons donc vous
avez cette boue carbonatées qui se forme
juste à côté du récif de corail donc
déjà il ya en train de vous mentir là le
monsieur en vous disant qu'il a
forcément été transportée très très loin
non non non non non non non la boue
carbonatées elles se forment à
l'intérieur du récif donc déjà le parce
qu'on le sait encore une fois parce
qu'on le voit aujourd'hui les lébous
carbonates et se trouve à l'intérieur
des récifs de coraux protégés de là
chants de la mer les bons carbonatées
très fines peuvent se déposer
donc voilà donc déjà il n'a pas à être
transportées spécialement loin le corail
lacaton b de 20 centimètres plus loin et
pouf il est dans la boue carbonates et
d'une
et de deux le corail la barrière de
corail une fois qu'elle est morte
la boue carbonates et elle continue de
se former parce que la barrière de
corail est toujours là et elles
s'accumulent et ça s'accumule jusqu'à
enterrer le corail voilà d'autant comme
il le dit le corail il a tendance à
s'enfoncer il a parce qu'il ya le
phénomène de subsidence qui se produit
plus il ya de plus il ya de cochonneries
plus elle s'enfonce c'est la gravité
donc plus y être cochonneries pu elle
s'enfonce donc la barrière de corail a
là un poids elle s'enfonce dans la boue
carbonate évidemment et voilà donc je
veux dire non il ya en train de vous
mentir le monsieur il est en train de
vous mentir
le corps a hissé il n'a pas besoin
d'être enterré tout de suite après sa
mort pas du tout mais absolument pas et
en plus la boue carbonates et elle est
juste à côté il n'a pas besoin d'être
transportés très très loin non plus et
alors une bicarbonate et très fines dans
un phénomène de délits génie vercel peu
je les hais les boues carbonates et
c'est ça qui donne les calcaires
lithographique que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure et je vous ai bien dire
ça se forme pas en milieu agitée en or a
mis un déluge universel c'est un milieu
très très très très très agitée qui veut
pas dire que tu vas pas trouver des
fossiles de moindre qualité entre eux
deux encore une fois
rappel pour ceux qui n'étaient pas là au
début les forêts dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure là
spécimen bridge les forêts de spécimens
ridge 27 forêt enterrer les unes sur les
autres tout avec leurs racines en place
là ce qui viens de vous dire sur le
transport c'est bullshit mais 100% 200%
bullshit le transport n'est absolument
pas une condition nécessaire absolument
pas et on appareils on a décrit noïd
aussi qu'ils ont été enterrés avec leurs
racines parce que les cris de oui disons
des genres de petites racines même si
c'est des animaux ils ont un joueur de
petit racines fait on cumule avec des
petites racines c'est pareil on les a
tout entier en place si ces trucs là
avaient été transportés de façon ils
sont faits de petits articles gros comme
ça qui sont empilés attachés les uns aux
autres comme ça si ce truc là avait été
transportée pendant un événement de
haute énergie s'écrit noïd l'a jamais on
les aurait trouvés à les kinoïdes noïd
crinoline donc voilà à quoi ça ressemble
un créneau ide en théorie s'il veut bien
voilà ça c'est quoi sans s'envoyer que
là il ya un petit des genres de petites
racines et puis en pratique
en pratique on tapait le fossile donc en
pratique on ya deux façons de les
trouver les créneaux ide dans un milieu
de haute énergie
voilà ce qu'on trouve donc on trouve ce
que je vous disais les petits articles
isolés qu'on appelle souvent d entre eux
et on peut trouver des fois des créneaux
id voit très souvent d'ailleurs en
amérique il ya des endroits où ça se
trouve on trouve des très très beau cri
dont ils vous envoyer quelques-uns déjà
s'afficher mais j'en veux vraiment
acquis à voile à la racine
voilà et des fois on trouve des créneaux
ide avec encore la racine même encore
attaché un truc vous voyez donc c'est
pareil ça ça ça n'a pas été enterré ça
n'a pas été enterré à 600 kilomètres de
l'endroit où ça a poussé un sas a été
enterré sur place dans son milieu de vie
et puis vite pour reprendre son exemple
du corail on a des barrières de corail
fossiles tout entière fossilisées dans
les ardennes par exemple on a des deux
lits dévonien on a des barrières de
corail tout entière faut l'utiliser sur
place donc non le transport
les transports n'est pas une évolution
nécessaire mais dont les corps est
vivant les milieux sont construits
d'accord tu es bien conscient que quand
on les trouve à des attitudes hervé
comme par exemple dans les ardennes on
en a qu'une on en a on en fait
l'hypothèse que les ardennes à l'époque
était en 10 euros pical il soutient la
dérive je sais pas où il veut en venir
avec sa queue que le déluge a déplacé
les coraux mais les allées c'est quand
même dans des latitudes tropicales a pas
du tout flou vont venir avec ça et puis
comme l'a en plus ça tombe bien parce
que je vous parlais des récifs
coralliens des ardennes les récifs
coralliens des ardennes ils sont tout
entiers fossilisés donc il n'y a aucune
raison de penser qu'ils ont été
déplacées je veux dire vous avez le
récif corallien entier qui est là et il
n'est pas du tout dans des latitudes
tropicales en tout cas pas aujourd'hui
donc ça veut dire que c'est les ardennes
qui se sont déplacés donc dérive des
continents donc pas déluge biblique
voilà
qui voulait revenir
[Rires]
mesdames et messieurs dr white ont
déduit donc alors comme les fossiles
sont exactement là où on s'attend qu'il
soit on en déduit qu'il y avait un
courant qui faisait le travail est
reconnu pour les coraux qu'on retrouve
l'attitude qu'ils sont pas au bon
endroit assez magique l'ex qui vient de
se produire pour pour pseudo retomber
sur ses pieds d'ailleurs fait comme il
est obligé comme dans sa théorie du
déluge il est obligé de dire que les
choses se sont déplacés super loin parce
que déluge forcément haute énergie etc
il est obligé de dire que les choses se
sont déplacés mais comme en même temps
il faut que ça reste cohérent avec le
fait qu'on retrouve les fossiles à des
latitudes tropicales ou au moins des
paléo latitudes tropicales
du coup le monsieur il est sa face à ce
moment là que je ne sais pas qu'est ce
que c'est que ça et où est ce qu'il ya
écrit dans la bible que le déluge à
créer des courants qui font autour de
l'équateur quoi de toute façon c'est
vraiment le truc mais qui ressort de
nulle part de nulle part j'ai dit ata
c'est une condition absolument
nécessaire à allah au soutien de sa
théorie que je veux dire c'est ça qui me
fait marrer en fait c'est que il est en
train de il est en train de se
compliquer l'existence à nous expliquer
un phénomène dont il n'a absolument pas
besoin en fin du mois j'ai encore une
fois jouent alors je vois pas où il veut
en venir
mais je n'avais pas besoin de faire
cette hypothèse-là arrête arrête tout
enfonce un bon on a trouvé que les
fossiles avaient été transformés
transporter de l'est à l'ouest
donc il suffit à être trouvé qu'un seul
fossiles qui a été transporté sur un
gradient nord-sud et c'est bon on a
gagné
ça tombe bien ça tombe bien j'ai ça j'ai
ça dans les tiroirs
ça tombe bien parce que dans mes cours
justement je parle d'un fossile celui là
voilà donc c'est un arc est aussi apte
qui datent du cambrien d'antarctique
sauf qu'on l'a retrouvé dans des roches
qui viennent du permien d'afrique
donc c'est un archéo siat qui a été
transporté donc voyez où était le pôle
sud ici voyez où étaient l'antarctique à
l'époque
vous voyez où l afrique du sud
aujourd'hui vous voyez où l antarctique
aujourd'hui donc quelles que soient que
vous preniez les latitudes d'aujourd'hui
où les où les paléo de l'attitude de
l'époque
ce fossile c'est pas du tout déplacer
enfin c'est s'est déplacé sur un
gradient nord-sud et pas du tout sur un
gradient est ouest voilà de dire là vous
voyez le pôle sud et l'a donc là on se
dirige vers le nord donc ce fossile
s'est déplacé sur un gradient nord-sud
voilà en tout cas si on prend les paléo
l'attitude sauf comme comme le monsieur
là il est créationniste
il doit pas croire à la théorie de la
dérive des continents ça je ne pense pas
donc pour lui l'antarctique a toujours
été en position où il est aujourd'hui et
alors là le gradient nord-sud il est
violent pour la déplacement de ce
fossile donc voilà mais comment on sait
que ce truc maintenant on va peut-être
expliquer quand même commencé que
stark est aussi advient d'antarctique et
s'est déplacé jusqu'en afrique bon bah
les arcs et au cias n'ont vécu au
cambrien ça on le sait je veux dire on a
des datation absolue qui montre que eux
ils ont vécu au cambrien les arcs et au
ciad sont des organismes qui ressemble à
des éponges qui n'ont vécu que au
cambrien et on n'a jamais trouvé d'arc
est aussi apte en afrique du sud
tout simplement parce que justement
l'afrique du sud n'a de toute façon il
ya quasiment aucun fossile au cambrien
en afrique du sud à part quelques
empreintes de pas de vertébrés et tout
ça l'afrique du sud était trop près du
pôle jusqu'à demain jusqu'au carbonifère
l'afrique du sud était trop près du pôle
pour avoir de jolies fossiles enfin de
moins on commence à trouver des fossiles
dans le devon hien il ya quelques belles
faune qui commencent à sortir du
dévonien mais en tout cas avant le
dévonien on va dire juste pour être safe
allez on va envahir tirer un petit peu
jusqu'au on a quand même des petits des
petits bras kyo qui sont trouvés dans
leur domicile
en tout cas au cambrien ya rien voilà le
cambrien c'est la montagne de la table à
au cap
donc le cambrien le de toute façon ça
s'appelle le la formation du cap
donc la montagne de la table au cap
c'est des dépôts cambrien et donc s'il y
avait des faux cils là dedans le saurait
je veux dire à vue où c'est localisé je
veux dire c'est juste à côté du musée a
littéralement du premier musée qui a été
fort fondée en afrique du sud et je
crois que même s'il ya des premiers
musées d'afrique tout court mais mais
bref
donc la montagne de la table c'est du
cambrien d'afrique du sud est il ya zéro
fossile de dent donc on est à peu près
sûr qu'il ya pas dark est aussi attendre
afrique du sud ça c'est clair
par contre on sait qu'en antarctique il
ya des arcs et au ciad de cette espèce
là qui se promènent enfin qui vivent à
cette époque-là en antarctique on sait
que les arcs et aussi hâte ne se
promènent pas justement parce que ce
sont des organismes fixent est un don
qui a rien d'autre qui a pu les déplacés
que un courant ça on en est à peu près
certain il n'y a rien d'autre qui a pu
les déplacer c'est pas eux mêmes qui se
sont déplacés donc c'est forcément un
courant de quelque chose qui les a
déplacés
c'est arqués et du coup on retrouve et
quand on a retrouvé du coup ce fossile
là on a vu que c'était un archéo siat on
a vu qu'il était de la même espèce que
ce d'antarctique mais selon antarctique
qui datent du cambrien alors que les
roches dans laquelle on a retrouvé cet
art comme sade date du père bien du
début du permien on le sait encore une
fois grâce aux adaptations absolue et
tout ça donc cet arc et au ciad c'est
forcément déplacées sur un gradient
entre l'antarctique et l'afrique qui
était déjà nord-sud à l'époque mais qui
est toujours nord-sud
aujourd'hui donc pas du tout le gradient
est-ouest dont il nous parle dont il
nous parle et la petite histoire c'est
qu'en fait ce qui a déplacé cet arc et
au ciad ce sont les glaciers justement
les classiers qui sont représentés ici
comme l'afrique était centrée sur le
pôle en fait les glaciers avancent et
jusqu'en antarctique recul est ensuite
en afrique rares avancées jusqu'en
antarctique reculait et donc à chaque
fois ça ramenait des blocs en fait la
glace emprisonner des blocs et en
fondant pendant l'été en afrique
drop est des blocs ce qu'on appelle des
ce qu'on appelle des titres voilà ici
donc ça drop des blocs ou des moraines
aussi on appelle ça en français dès
moraines donc ça drop dès moraines comme
ça pingping sur le passage et donc c'est
moraine occasionnels peuvent
occasionnellement peuvent contenir un
fossile donc un fossile qui qui sera
plus ancien que la roche dans laquelle
il se dépose ici un fossile du cambrien
donc voilà
donc le courant en question n'est pas un
courant est ouest d'eau
c'est un courant nord enfin c'est un
courant nord sud ou en l'occurrence sud
nord puisque c'est le pôle c'est un
courant sud nord de glace en réalité
encore une fois le déluge n'est pas
responsable du dépôt de ce fossile
alors que pourtant alors que pourtant le
cambrien et le permien font totalement
partie de cette période pendant laquelle
il dit que le déluge a eu lieu c'est
dommage
c'est dommage perdu perdu c'est qu'on
sait qu'on n'y avait qu'un fossile qui
pouvait montrer que tu avais tort
c'était celui-là
les empreintes de pas ça ça va être
intéressant
[Rires]
alors deux affirmations première
affirmation les empreintes fossilisées
sont trouvés dans des environnements
toujours sous l'eau alors déjà va
falloir m'expliquer comment un d alors
encore une fois on est dans un contexte
de délits l'universel
un déluge universel qui a massacré tout
le monde
comment ces fossiles se sont formés sous
une couche d'eau qui a recouvert le mont
everest
vous avez deux heures après sa deuxième
condition à l'air de suggérer qu'en fait
les empreintes fossiles se sont formées
avant le déluge mais malin malin bon
alors ça va t'il du coup du coup les
fossiles se sont pas formés pendant dé
lui
contrairement à ce qui est annoncé dans
la dans le titre mais bref
alors les empreintes fossiles se sont
formés du coup avant le déluge
mais ça c'est vrai
on attend première condition on va on va
pas aller trop vite on va pas les deux
premières conditions les fossiles se
sont formés les empreintes fossiles se
sont toutes formées dans l'eau l'heure
est au lit là et au lit elle est au lit
des traces de pas voilà et leur équipe
ont découvert une piste d'emprunt ne pas
conserver dans une succession de
conditions favorables le dépôt d'une
couche d'environ 15 centimètres de
cendres fine d'une éruption du volcan
sadima voilà alors la seule trace douala
et au lycée une averse légère qui a
cimenté la couche de cendre à la
transformation du tube volcanique sans
détruire les empreintes
voilà c'est la seule intervention de
l'eau sur le site de la et au lit une
averse légère on peut voir les gouttes
de pluie d'ailleurs sur le site de
lahitolle il ya des fossiles de gouttes
de pluie je déconne pas et le scellement
du site
non pas par l'eau mais par le dépôt
d'autres cendres venu la recouvrir elle
a protégé la et oli est un site 100%
réalisé sur de la cendre volcanique sans
eau du tout à part l'eau de pluie qui
est venue consolider la sambre
c'est tout et on parle d'une légère
averse dont on peut voir encore les
empreintes de gouttes d'eau sur le site
on parle pas d'un déluge universel et
ensuite il ya eu de nouveaux de la
cendre par dessus voilà
bon maintenant que les uns les
empreintes de pas sont formés la nana
dans des toujours dans des milieux
aquatiques
non non on a aussi des empreintes de
dinosaures qui sont formés à la cendre
volcanique en afrique du sud
d'ailleurs donc n'ont toujours pas avait
d'ailleurs l'un truc que j'ai oublié de
montrer
le salagou salagou l éléphante de
dessiccation des formes de dessiccation
du salagou que j'ai oublié de montrer
aussi magnifique forme de dessiccation
regardez regardez moi ça quand elles
sont belles ces formes de dessiccation
la voie celle là ça c'est des formes de
dessiccation moderne ça c'est les formes
de dessiccation qui se forme quand vous
aviez halak que cela que s'est asséchée
et qu'ensuite large il a séché et du
coup commencé à craquer comme ça mais au
lac du salagou en dans le languedoc donc
à côté de montpellier est bien coté de
lodève plus particulièrement vous avez
ça ça ce sont des formes de dessiccation
fossiles qui datent du père bien c'est
pareil
comment vous avez des ventes de
dessiccation fossiles dans votre modèle
du déluge où il ya de l'eau partout
qu'elle se sont formés après ben non
regardez il ya des rituels marque au
dessus des formes de dessiccation c'est
basiquement au lac du salagou c'est ça
que vous avez un d alternance entre des
rippel marque
c'est à dire dépôt d'eau peu profonde
qui ont marqué le sable où les vagues
ont marqué le sable et une défendre de
dessiccation et des rippeurs marque
éléphant de dessiccation lrip elles
marquent donc une alternance entre eau
peu profonde et sèche et sécheresses et
puis c'est super bien donc c'est profond
c'est profond il ya encore tout le
mésozoïque à venir au dessus donc le
mésozoïque qui s'est pas formé au-dessus
s'enlaçant l'aide du déluge
donc comment ça se fait qu'on a des
formes de dessiccation en plein milieu
du déluge
un petit malin et et en plus on salagou
vous savez ce qu'on a on alla lieu de on
à la lieude c'est où il ya des
empreintes de pas dans les fentes de
dessiccation les fentes de dessiccation
fossiles que vous voyez très bien là
elles sont marquées d'empreintes de pas
d'animaux qui ont marché donc dans un
environnement sec sec
c'est bon d'avoir raison c'est bon
d'avoir raison donc il raconte n'importe
quoi voilà il raconte n'importe quoi et
il n'y a pas besoin de voyager très très
loin pour le savoir parce que l'exemple
de la lettonie c'était c'est vrai c'est
un peu exotique et tout ça il suffit
d'aller en france voilà dans le sud de
la france pendant les vacances là vous
allez dans le sud de la france vous
allez voir la lieude vous avez les
formes de dessiccation avec les aux
empreintes dedans donc donc les
empreintes se sont formés dans le
sédiment quand le sédiment était encore
meubles l'impossible videmment et le
sédiment c'est que vous pouvez pas
mettre d'empreintes dedans donc les
emplois ne se sont formés dans le
sédiment meubles et ensuite sécheresse
pas inondations le moment sécheresse
mauvaise chronologie
donc là il est en train de nous
expliquer que un amphibien était en
train de marcher les pieds dans l'eau
c'est bien c'est bien je n'ai rien à
dire sur son interprétation de ça c'est
très bien c'est très bien j'attends
encore qu'il nous montre le parce qu'il
ya encore le deuxième point le deuxième
point c'est les squelettes qui sont
au-dessus systématiquement des sont
systématiquement au-dessus des
empreintes
ce qui est fondamentalement très très
fort ce qui est fondamentalement
extrêmement faut encore une fois la
france
en france le registre fossile des
empreintes de pas notamment de
dinosaures et concentrées
essentiellement dans la fin du trias et
le début du jurassique donc à la fin du
trias vous avez des empreintes de thirau
terium par exemple qui n'est pas encore
un dinosaure d'ailleurs c'est un
archosaures mais bref vous avez quiero
terium à la fin du trias et ensuite au
début du jurassique c'est là que vous
avez le festival des empreintes de pas
de dinosaures vous en trouver partout
dans le larzac notamment et c'est le
début du jurassique ça veut dire que les
dinos c'est le début du jurassique
donc ça veut dire que en gros enfin les
dinosaures ils sont déjà là depuis la
fin du trias dire les dinosaures on en a
deux la fin du trias on en a du début du
jurassique aussi on a été hors d'eau
thooris ici en afrique du sud au début
dû à la fin du trias bas on a on a les
dinosaures sud américains comme et aux
raptor par exemple donc voilà je veux
dire on n'a pas non ils sont au moins en
même temps et puis après vous avez tout
un tas d'empreintes de pas du crétacé
donc je ne sais pas d'où ça sort cette
idée les empreintes de pas de là et au
lit que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
elles sont elles sont à peu près du même
âge qu'eux
lucie que le squelette lucy
l'australopithèque us ce qui veut dire
qu'elles sont déjà vachement plus jeune
que toumaï par exemple qui lui à sept
millions d'années
donc je ne sais pas d'où sort cette idée
que les empreintes de pas enfin je veux
dire les empreintes de pas ne sont pas
toutes concentrées justement c'est comme
je vous disais la prévision que fait
cette personne en disant le déluge est
responsable de tout le registre fossile
c'est que vous ne pouvez avoir qu'un
seul horizon de palais au sol tout en
bas avant le déluge et c'est le seul
horizon de palais au sol donc dans son
idée à lui il faut que toutes les
empreintes de pas ce soit sur cet ancien
palais au sol mais c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai du tout je veux dire des
empreintes de pas on en a depuis que les
tétrapodes marche on en a depuis que les
tétrapodes marche on en a déjà deux del
démonière moyen des empreintes de pas de
tétrapodes et on n'en trouve pas jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je veux dire on a
des empreintes de pas de néandertal dans
le cénozoïque et on a des empreintes de
pas à tous les niveaux donc non c'est
que c'est absolument fou c'est
totalement faux 7e jeu mais là s'il ya
de drôle c'est qu'il est quand même en
train de nous expliquer les il est en
train d'essayer de convaincre le monde
que cet amphibien marcher dans l'eau un
amphibien jeu indice un indice chez vous
cet amphibien amphibiens donc non moi je
suis pas gêné par cette interprétation
oui il a raison dans l'absolu cet
amphibien marcher dans l'eau je veux te
revoir faire ça avec les empreintes de
dinosaures sauropodes dans la les
empreintes de dinosaures de plagne
voilà où de salah goudjil la plagne
empreinte la rigueur mais non j'ai pas
dis plague je te revois refaire cette
interprétation avec ses empreintes là
maintenant des antennes de plage c'est
pas un machin de 49,2 me fait plaisir
c'est toi plaisir
donc voilà donc encore une fois de le
problème c'est qu'un déluge universel
implique forcément qui a pas eu de dépôt
d'empreintes de pas pendant le déluge
parce qu'évidemment il y avait plus
l'endroit où marché sauf que c'est pas
le cas du tout sauf que c'est pas être
qu'à lui tout le paléozoïque et le
mésozoïque donc là où lui même a dit que
le daily mail avait lieu à leur appel ne
pas aller au zoo lesquels mésozoïque
sont constellés d'empreintes de pas à
tous les niveaux moussa dago prins donc
quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive ce qu'il dit
s'applique à la plupart des empreintes
de dinosaures
ça veut dire qu'il ya des exceptions
notez le quelque part dans les dents les
empreintes qu'on a en france d'ailleurs
il ya des empreintes de dinosaures où on
a même des les écailles qui sont
préservés ça s'est pas formé dans l'eau
ça c'est le sédiment été sec qu'enfin
était quasiment sec quand ça c'est fort
mais il peut pas être complètement sec
et je veux dire c'était une boue
quasiment sèche
autrement vous pouvez pas conserver les
empreintes des écailles dessus donc
c'est pareil c
il ay la cdu chile picking dans le sens
où il a pris les empreintes qui
l'arrangeait pour vous les montrer mais
autrement
autrement c'est il ya plein d'empreintes
qui contredisent le ski dit on peut le
faire un dinosaure footprint skies
voilà donc des dinosaures et des
empreintes de dinosaures on voit les
écailles imprimés ben vous voyez par
exemple magnifique magnifique empreintes
de dinosaures avec les écailles imprimés
et puis même en français je pense que
empreintes de dinosaures je pense que je
peux trouver empreintes de dinosaures
avec les écailles la peau des dinosaures
révélée par les empreintes
voilà ci ont sévi l'emprunter très peu
profondes ce qui est cohérent avec le
fait que enfin là c'est une contre
emprunte pour le coup donc c'est le
c'est de l'autre côté en fait de
l'empreinte mais bref c'est une contre
empreintes mais vous voyez dans
l'empreinte est très peu profondes ce
qui est cohérent avec un sédiment
quasiment sec avec les écailles
préserver dessus ce qui n'aurait pas pu
arriver dans un sable mouillé dessous
locaux sous l'os à henry puis voilà ça
fait des enfants dégueulasse exactement
les empreintes dégueulasse qui va vous
montrer la voilà donc là il va vous
montrer des empreintes de dégueulasse en
vous disant vous voyez ça c'est des
empreintes de dinosaures qui ont été
faites sous l'eau je ne conteste pas ça
il ya des empreintes de dinosaures qui
ont été faites sous un filet d'eau
effectivement mais et à des empreintes
de dinosaures qui ont été faits dans des
sédiments sec
et puis il ya les empreintes de la
lionne qui a été fait dans un sédiment
qui a séché après ce qui est encore pire
puisque ça veut dire que ça a été suivie
d'une sécheresse pas d'un déluge
je n'ai pas commenter sur le fait qu'il
semble suggérer juste sur sa diapos
qu'il y aurait des empreintes humaine
je ne vais pas trop rebondir dessus
c'est encore une fois c'est ça a été dit
répété des milliards de fois que les
empreintes qui avait l'air d'être des
empreintes humaine justement sont des
empreintes de dinosaures qui ont été
déformés par le fait que c'est que les
empreintes étaient formés sous l'eau et
que du coup en fait vous avez le
sédiment qui part sur le côté quand le
pied se soulève
ça fait un mouvement de pompes qui on
est en fait les bords de l'empreinte
sera date mais du coup ça donne
l'impression que ça fait un pied du mur
humain tout donc je vais pas aller comme
il n'en parle pas je vais pas en parler
plus mais voilà là il parle de là que je
sais pas où il va avec cette histoire de
que nous sommes le 10 octobre 2017
[Rires]
on a un mec qui croient encore que les
dinosaures traîner leurs que par terre
comme dans les années 50 c'est pitoyable
[Rires]
c'est pitoyable
mais là elle est les dinosaures tenait
lors que loin du sol comme les oiseaux
tiennent leur queue loin du sol à le
dire le là que d'un oiseau avec des
longues plumes et pas plus lourde que la
queue d'un dinosaure samples humain que
la queue osseuse d'un dinosaure sans
plumes mais pourtant les deux tiennent
leur cul très loin du sol on me dira
puis j'ai pas moi regarde les oryx
theron par exemple
prendre un animal qui a une longue queue
oryctérope armorique t rop quand il
marche 1
il a la queue au dessus du sol après
quand ils s'arrêtent oui là quand ils
s'arrêtent là qu elle touche je veux
bien mais quand ils marchent quand ils
se déplacent quand ils laissent des
empreintes de pas donc que est pourtant
là qu elle descend un peu le dire donc
là on est déjà quand même sur un niveau
de pas dinosaures et puis on va toutes
les preuves anatomy qui leur disent que
les dinosaures donnez-leur que voilà dès
lors que comme ça que j'ai vraiment
besoin d'expliquer quoi que toutes les
preuves anatomique montrent que les
dinosaures tenait alors que comme ça on
a les attaches musculaire on à
l'articulation des vertèbres et qu'ils
monteront à tout le monde qu'il faut
faire il faut faire faire des
contentions pas possible c'est assez ce
qu'elle est là pour que leur que
traînent par terre donc la natation
c'est en retard de 50 ans veut dire
qu'il ya une raison mécanique très
simple au fait que les dinosaures
traînez pas leur que derrière eux c'est
la même que pour l'oryctérope c'est que
laisser traîner ça que par terre va
sacrer un frottement et que ce
frottement ce frottement d'une ça fait
mal et de deux ça et de deux ça vous
freine un point c'est tout et que les
dinosaures le dire tous dans leur
anatomie encore une fois regarder ce
théropodes mais c'était au delà tout
dans l'art anatomy creek ce sont des
animaux coureurs qui ont besoin d'aller
vite
c'est l'heure c'est leur credo d'aller
vite donc ils vont pas laisser traîner
leurs que traîner par terre des raisons
très logique à cela la seule raison pour
laquelle les crocodiles ont leur cas qui
traîne à terre c'est quand il c'est
parce qu'elles se sont des animaux qui
ont les bras sur le côté du corps et que
du coup ça leur prend plus d'énergie à
soulever le corps car à rester qu'à
laisser traîner leurs colocataires
voilà c'est tout un dinosaure ça leur
aurait pris plus d'énergie de laisser
traîner là que par terre qu'autre chose
c'est la raison pour l'heure été rope
ça que quand il marche c'est parce que
quand ils marchent bailo pas laisser
traîner ça que par terre parce que ça
ferait ça l'annulerait ils risqueraient
des septicémies et cela freinerait
négligence totale du site de burgès
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
il est en train de vous dire que dans le
cambrien on trouve pas de fossiles de
trilobites on ne trouve que des fossiles
de on ne trouve que des fossiles de crue
diana donc des empreintes de trilobites
c'est vrai en afrique du sud
c'est vrai en afrique du sud on ne
trouve que des empreintes de trilobites
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est vrai par contre en amérique du
nord
parce qu'en plus il est noir américain
là ils utilisent les fit est tout seul à
des pieds au lieu de dire des maîtres
dont il est forcément dans américain le
monsieur il devrait être au courant d'un
petit site paléontologique qui s'appelle
les schistes de burgès dans lequel on a
retrouvé quelques milliers de fossiles
de trilobites moi même j'en ai trouvé
j'avais fait une vidéo à l'époque une
marque et burges entracte science voilà
donc le berger centract science vidéo
s'il veut bien y aller voilà donc
j'étais parti aux schistes de burgess et
puis j'ai trouvé vous profitiez de
mauvais en double le premier fossile que
je vous montre dans la vidéo c'est un
trilobites agnostique des essais du
cambrien inférieur un des schistes de
l'urgent est donc séduit le début non
c'est du cambrien moyens et du cambrien
moyens il me semble schiste de burgès
mais en hng angle il me semble qu'ils
aient du cambrien a fait rien mais bon
voilà c'est un trio guitare
trois modes voilà attendait xingjiang je
vais vérifier quand même que shenzhen il
est bien qu'en voyant inférieur sur le
sight 512 millions d'années alors lis
cambrian début du camp royal et chaque
géant vient aussi des trilobites qui ont
été trouvés là il voit la magnifique
magnifique trilobites de chennegy angle
cambrien inférieur bisous bécaud donc ça
ça ça porte un nom ce qu'il vient de
dire et ça s'appelle un mensonge
ça s'appelle un énorme mensonge ça
s'appelle un mensonge ou il est
gravement incompétent parce que négliger
l'existence des trilobites au cambrien
inférieur enfin négliger l'existence de
faux cils de corps de trilobites n'est
pas seulement d'empreintes dans le
cambrien inférieure soit on est un
énorme menteur et dans ce cas là je vois
pas l'intérêt de regarder cette vidéo
puisque ce monsieur est un menteur soit
on est un énorme incompétent et dans ce
cas là pareil je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de regarder cette vidéo et encore moins
de lalique et comme 5200 personnes en
fait la traduction la traduction d'enfer
qui traduit shell en au but alors oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on en anglais
shell ça veut aussi dire au but là ça
voulait dire coquillages comme rien dire
c'est pas vrai non non non je te faire
sa modeste taille nous sommes juste
regarder qu'est ce qui nous dit oldest
candidat moussa sow russe alors grâce à
son riche n'est pas encore un dinosaure
c'est un dinosaure aux morts on va
prendre aux raptor d'ailleurs j'avais
parlé des eaux raptor et aux raptor donc
le plus vieux l'un des plus vieux
dinosaures on va dire 231 228 millions
d'années 220 millions d'années
voilà donc et aux raptor et pluvieux de
10 millions d'années de la première des
innocents footprint 221 presse et une
recherche a vite fait mal fait mais
c'est juste pour dire que s'il avait une
gueule et déjà il aurait peut-être mais
ce sera peut-être automne une connerie
vous remarquerez lombard fait d'ailleurs
qu'il ne retire le projet il ya aucune
preuve de ce que serait la rencontre
après je suis d'accord avec lui qu'on a
rarement des fossiles dos et d'en
préserver ensemble
de s'échapper
c'est moi les emprunteurs en jeu jean
prince les empreintes sont toujours
formés dans des milieux où le sédiment
est très très faim donc des milieux de
basse énergie déjà d'une ou dans des
palais au sol dans des milieux où il ya
zéro énergie puisque c'est des palais au
sol et ces milieux là sont très très
très rarement recouvert par des
poudingue donc des milieux de haute
énergie nous faites ce que vous voulez
de cette information là on trouve
quasiment jamais de poudingue par dessus
des directement au dessus des empreintes
voilà un un animal qui essayaient de
s'échapper du déluge saurait dire
immédiatement recouvert les empreintes
serait immédiatement recouvert par un
peu dingue alors la regarder comme il a
il est passé de du coca light
maintenant ils vous parlent de
disparités diversité vous avez remarqué
l'absence totale de transition entre les
empreintes de pas et ce qu'il dit
maintenant bon là on est sûr clairement
on est en train de vous bouchité la
façon on est en train de vous assommer
d'informations mais qui vont toutes dans
le même sens à savoir dire que les
scientifiques sont des incompétents ce
qu'ils ne sont pas donc bref des
incompétents au des menteurs encore une
fois comme j'ai dit ah le le
créationnisme suffisamment proche du
complotisme le créationnisme a besoin du
complotisme pour au moins croire que les
scientifiques sont soit des incompétents
soit des menteurs donc et puis c'est
jargonneux à souhait donc là il se lance
dans diversité disparités alors
évidemment faut expliquer ce que ces
diversités disparités la diversité c'est
le nombre d'espèces la disparité
cela-dit
errance morphologiques écologique entre
ces espèces donc par exemple chez les
mammifères
vous avez une énorme diversité de
rongeurs en termes d'espèces mais ils
ont tous une gueule de rongeurs vous
avez aussi une énorme diversité de
chauves souris mais ce sont tous des
choses sourit donc 5000 espèces de
mammifères antho un tiers ce sont des
rongeurs l'autre pied à ce sont des
chauves souris et le dernier tiers est
basse et tout le reste
depuis la musaraigne jusqu'à l'éléphant
donc en fait vous avez un tiers de
rongeurs qui a une très forte diversité
une très faible disparités un tiers de
chauves souris c'est pareil très forte
diversité en nombre d'espèces mais très
faible disparités parce qu'elles ont
toutes la même tranche et après vous
avez le dernier tiers qui est très
faible diversité du coup vu qu'il ya
beaucoup moins d'espèces mais très
fortes disparités puisque vous avez de
tout allant de la petite musaraigne à la
taupe à l'éléphant au chevalet jusqu'à
la baleine bleue donc ça c'est une forte
disparité ça avec une très faible
diversité
donc ça voilà la notion de diversité de
disparités c'est des notions d'écologie
qui sont quand même assez compliqué à
envisager avant où il va avec ça mais
honnêtement je comprends pas trop
chercher les créationnistes sont
généralement très un arbre
phylogénétique vous venez de voir le
jour mais devant un arbre phylogénétique
dans un champ d'une conférence
créationnistes qui est un événement en
dépression annoncée
regardez il est là il ya un arbre
phylogénétique dans une présentation
créationnistes il est là il ya je tenais
juste à faire un arrêt sur images
c'est faux c'est faux là il est en train
de nous expliquer que pour créer de la
disparité avec la théorie de l'évolution
le dire pour avoir de beaucoup de
disparités il faudrait du cou qui est
beaucoup d'événements de spéciation et à
chaque spéciation on se spécialise un
petit peu plus créant de crayon ainsi un
écart et donc de la disparité ouimet et
donc du coup à la fin on devrait obtenir
vlad espèces du coup parce que du coup à
chaque fois il a fallu qu'ils aient
spéciation pour obtenir de la disparité
oui mais enfin déjà déjà on
identifierait probablement pas ça si
c'était vrai on identifiera est pas ça
pour de la disparité puisqu'on aurait
absolument tous les intermédiaires entre
deux états qu'on considérerait comme
disparates
donc je prends un exemple tout con mais
est-ce qu'on considérerait réellement
l'éléphant si différents que ça d'une
gazelle si on avait absolument toutes
les différentes tailles entre les deux
s'il y avait aucun aucune cassure entre
les deux je dirais ce qu'on considérait
vraiment l'éléphant comme
significativement différent d'une
gazelle je ne sais pas c'est juste pour
dire que voilà déjà si on a tout le
continuum
est ce qu'on considérait vraiment ça
comme de la disparité d'un point de vue
purement sémantique mais c'est surtout
son sa prédiction comme quoi la théorie
de l'évolution ne peut pas expliquer la
disparité parce qu' il faudrait créer
beaucoup de diversité a là un énorme
défaut qui est très très évident c'est
qu'elle néglige l'existence des
extinctions les extinctions c'est un
phénomène qui existe
on le sait même les créationnistes
peuvent pas nier que l'événement va que
c'est que ça existe les extinctions le
dit alors on en voit suffisamment des
espèces qui s'étaient tous les jours je
dire ça fait suffisamment la une des
journaux la le dernier rhinocéros machin
le dernier dauphin bidule qui
s'éteignent comme ça pour que pour qu'on
sache que l'extinction est un événement
qui existe et donc à partir du moment où
les espèces peuvent s'éteindre
on s'attend pas forcément accroître la
diversité pour atteindre une grande
disparité la version 1.0 écrase la
version
0 point 0 et la version 2.0 écrase la
version 1.0 et ainsi de suite
d'autant que c'est ce qu'on s'attend à
voir du point de vue évolutif c'est à
dire que si on va vers plus de
disparités donc vers plus de
spécialisation l'espèce la plus
spécialisée issu d'une classe d'une
classe de génèse va remplacer l'espèce
ou moins spécialisés puisqu'elle est
plus spécialisée donc voilà après c'est
en partant du principe qu'il ya une
pression de sélection vers la
spécialisation donc c'est simplifier ce
que j'ai à dire mais clairement
clairement il ya un truc là clairement
il ya un truc de fou en fait c'est il ya
2 il ya deux types de créationnistes 1
il ya le bon et il ya le mauvais
créationnistes le bon créationnistes ils
vous donnent des arguments que vous avez
du mal qui vous donne du fil à retordre
voilà et puis elle mauvais
créationnistes celui dont les arguments
ceux des bugs
en deux mots et là ils viennent nous
donner un argument qui se dé bonnes
quand un mot extinction
donc c'est un argument qui est
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement
jargonneux je veux dire faut aller sur
la diversité la disparité expliqué les
deux mots expliqué qu'elle et la
prédiction que ferait la théorie de
l'évolution si jamais il fallait
atteindre de la disparité il faudrait
qu'ils aient plein d'espèces du cours
entre les deux donc on pourrait pas
atteindre de la disparité sans avoir
beaucoup de diversité faut arriver à
expliquer tout ça pour au final bien
vous voyez la théorie de l'évolution est
fausse parce qu'on ne devrait pas avoir
de la disparité sans avoir beaucoup de
diversité et la halle évolutionniste
vous réponds bah oui mais enfin il ya
les extinctions t'es con voilà ça se
désole quand un mot bah ouais mais tu
viens de négliger totalement l'existence
des extinctions extinction un mot et
pour tout ont tout au tout la belle
prédictions s'effondre complètement
si les espèces s'éteignent t'es pas
obligé d'atteindre une immense
disparités t'es pas obligé d'avoir une
immense diversité pour atteindre une
immense disparités les espèces
s'éteignent au fur et à mesure
voilà donc je vous laisse décider si ce
mec est un bon créationnistes wamin
iphonistes à mon avis là il vient de
toucher le fond stephen jay gould mon
préféré
les créationnistes adore stephen jay
gould isadore cité stephen jay gould et
niels eldredge surtout en absence de
contexte parce que niels eldredge et
stephen jay gould
ils ont beaucoup critiqué le paradigme
de la théorie de l'évolution donc ils
ont beaucoup de catch fraises qui
contredisent la théorie de l'évolution
sauf que eux ils n'ont pas fait parce
qu'ils étaient créationnistes eux ils
l'ont fait parce qu'à leur époque
la théorie de l'évolution était plus ou
moins égales au gradualisme fils éthique
ou du moins c'est ce qu'il voulait que
les gens croient en les lisant donc la
théorie de l'évolution pour eux c'était
le gradualisme si l'éthique et veut ils
ont beaucoup critiqué le gradualisme
fils éthique parce qu'ils ont proposé
leurs théories déséquilibre ponctué où
les espèces n'évoluez pas graduellement
mais par petits bonds c'est ce que vous
voyez là d'ailleurs ça c'est un bel
exemple d'arbres construit sur le modèle
des équilibres ont tué au moins sept
branches la cua donc cette branche là
c'est du gradualisme et cette branche là
celle de l'equilibre ponctué donc dont
ils ont beaucoup balancé des cats
fraises contre la théorie de l'évolution
mais pour eux la théorie de l'évolution
c'était le gradualisme cinétique le
paradigme de la théorie de l'évolution
c'était le gradualisme fils éthiques
donc ils ont plein de cash prize comme
ça qui contredisent la théorie de
l'évolution mais qui ont mec qui sortis
de leur contexte du coup certes beaucoup
les créationnistes et c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont sous lé toujours cité par
les créationnistes c'est à cause de ces
quatre fraises alors qu'est ce qu'il a
dit stephen jay gould aurait dit vous
êtes vous vous attendez à ce que la
diversité précède la disparité je suis à
peu près sûr que la phrase suivante de
stephen jay gould qui ne citera pas
était et après la diversité c'est un du
coup il ne reste plus que la disparité
mais ça évidemment il va pas vous le
dire je n'aime pas aller vérifier si
cette phrase existe honnêtement je vais
partir du principe que c'est vrai parce
que les créationnistes aime beaucoup
cité les phrases de stephen jay gould
hors contexte une fois de plus parce que
c'était un personnage médiatique et puis
parce que comme j'ai dit l'aimé bien
mettre des taquets comme ça à la au
paradigme évolutif gradualiste mais il
faut aller vérifier s'il a vraiment dit
honnêtement ça de toute façon c'est
comme j'ai dis le le simple fait de
rajouter extinction dans la sauce rend
la sauce complètement caduque donc à
bastien maintenant il existe les jeux
[Rires]
c'est marrant ça tout à l'heure quand
ils en ont quand il aurait dû en avoir
besoin là quand il nous parlait des
trilobites on trouve pas de corps de
trilobites fossiles iseo cambria l'aller
les schistes de burgès il n'existait pas
et villa maintenant qu'il en a besoin
parce que justement là il a envie de
nous expliquer que la disparité des
schistes de burgès est très élevé en
l'absence de diversité
1 la salle arrange la la salle arrange
parce que dans son petit monde à lui la
diversité doit forcément venir avant la
disparité si le contexte évolutionniste
est vrai enfin si la théorie de
l'évolution est vrai la diversité
devrait précéder la disparité ce n'est
pas le cas dans les schistes de burgès
donc là maintenant il les connaît les
schistes de burgess tiens c'est marrant
ça un bel exemple de caillette des
cerises comme dirait l'autre
donc maintenant il connaît les schistes
de burgess oui mais koné tulle shenyang
connais-tu chaque bilan mon bon ami dans
ce cas chen yang alors dans les schistes
de burgès on a donc les schistes de
burgess qui ont 515 millions d'années je
crois qu'ils sont du cambrien du tout
début du cambrien moyens si je ne
m'abuse ou la toute fin du cambrien
supérieur il me semble que ses débuts
cambria moyens mais bref 515 milliards
d'années ces schistes de burgès donc là
c'est un site
c'est le site officiel du fils de
georges s vous avez 150 espèces qui ont
été découvertes donc 150 espèces tout
animal à la librairie tout ça qui ont
été découverts aux schistes de burgess
pendant ce temps à chen yang donc chaque
jiang qui est un site qui est plus vieux
que les sites de burgès ton quand on
s'attendrait à trouver plus de diversité
dans les schistes de burgès si la
théorie de l'évolution
non on s'attendrait à trouver plus de
diversité à chen yang qui est plus vieux
que les schistes de burgès si la théorie
de l'évolution est vrai et bien cet
article nous annonce qu'il y à 228
espèces qui ont été découvertes à
shenyang contre les 150 des schistes de
burgès voilà voilà
robin il ya plus de diversité dans des
sachets nyanga burges a évidemment vous
allez me dire il ya plein de billets de
fossilisation qui peuvent rentrer dans
le conte etc
mais ça veut juste dire que moi aussi je
peux cueillir des cerises comme le veut
pour avoir raison oui bon ça veut
surtout dire que c'est un très mauvais
argument ce qui tient le registre de
burgès peut-être que les schistes de
murs les schistes de burgès et une
préservation exceptionnelles d'un seul
site
donc évidemment vous pouvez inclure tous
les billets que vous voulez là dedans
c'est là c est comme je dis c'est que m
c'est bien c'est qu'ils viennent se
contredit en fait s'est-il dit là dans
un contexte dans un contexte évolutif
évolutionniste il dit la diversité doit
précéder la disparité ce qui est pas
vrai comme je les aime à le dire puisque
d'unia les extinctions mais en plus il
ya un autre phénomène que j'ai négligé
mais c'est que une fois que la disparité
est atteinte
donc on a deux différences donc on a des
différences qui sont suffisamment
grandes pour que nous lui être humain
les qualifiant de disparates
ça n'empêche pas après ces disparités de
produire de la diversité une fois de
plus
donc si je prends pas encore une fois
prenons les rongeurs et les chauves
souris les rougeurs et les chauves
souris sont disparates
elles sont très très différentes les
unes des autres par contre à l'intérieur
des rongeurs vous avez un tiers de la
diversité des mammifères et à
l'intérieur en nombre d'espèces et à
l'intérieur des chauves souris vous avez
encore un autre tiers de la diversité en
nombre d'espèces des mammifères
donc chacun est disparate comparer l'un
à l'autre et chacun est aussi très
diverse qu'on en terme absolu en nombre
absolu d'espèces donc encore une fois
disparités n'exclut pas diversité et
donc là il ya de se contredire
magistralement jédir vient de se
contredire magistralement aussi en
disant qu' il n'y a que cinq classes
d'arthropodes aujourd'hui alors qu'ils
en avaient vingt-et-une avant donc du
coup ça veut dire que la diversité du
coup ça veut dire que c'est
la disparité change plus que la
diversité du coup dans ce système là
enfin bref tout ça veut dire quoi du
coup c'est pas la prédiction du tout que
tu as fait tout à l'heure la prédiction
que tu as fait s'il devait d'abord y
avoir de la diversité ensuite de la
disparité et là tu es en train de nous
dire qu'avant il y avait beaucoup de
disparités maintenant il ya moins de
disparités
donc j'ai en fait une prédiction de quoi
ça techniquement c'est une prédiction de
du créationnisme
non certainement pas c'est une
prédiction des extinctions de la
disparité qui a disparu il ya des
extinctions qui ont eu lieu ce qu'elle
disait tout à l'heure en plus donc là
évidemment voilà maintenant je vois un
peu mieux oui va donc il va nous dire
bah évidemment là il n'y a pas eu de ya
pas eu de diversité avant d'y avoir de
la disparité donc fatalement l'évolution
elle est complètement fausse
bah non encore une fois on retour à chen
yang
donc il nous dit va espèces
d'arthropodes à chaque gang avant burges
donc combien on a d'espèces
d'arthropodes donc avant burges on a cet
article me dis qu'on à 60,84 espèces
d'arthropodes pas 20 84 donc plus de
dire plus de diversité voilà avec à peu
près la même disparité à shenyang et la
burj est ce qu'ils vérifient très bien
la prédiction de stephen jackson
extraction qui est en jeu entre
zhang yang du coup pas ce qui est
dommage c'est que ce qui est dommage
c'est qu'il vienne par les légistes de
burgès mais enfin encore une fois le ce
qui vient de nous expliquer la le
legrand la grande inondation qui emporte
tout ouïe mêle la grande inondation qui
emporte tout va pas emporté que
l'écosystème terrestre elle va emporter
tout l'écosystème donc la disparité qui
devraient être représentées dont on
négocie dans ton dans son registre
fossile créé par le par la grande
inondation
elle devrait pas seulement inclure des
éléments terrestres comme tu viens de le
dire où elle devrait pas seulement
inclure uniquement des éléments marins
comme à burges elle devrait inclure tout
donc en fait même la disparité là que tu
viens de prédire elle est même encore
loin en dessous de la vérité elle est
très très loin en dessous de la vérité
et puis ça c'est sans compter le nombre
incalculable d'assemblage fin de dépôt
fossiles avec assemblage ou mono
spécifiques
je veux dire attendez
ah je vais vous montrer une photo c'est
mnhn donc à paris mnhn les comment ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle les sources un
bon c'est pas là j'arrive pas à le
trouver
on trinque pour sa fossiles mais de
toute façon vous avez vous avez
exactement la même philosophie ici voilà
donc magnifique magnifique le fossile un
assemblage de coquilles saint jacques
pour le vent du bio saines à la donc des
pectines fossiles ou et la disparité
s'il vous plaît le chercher a dit la
disparité donc au muséum d'histoire
naturelle de paris il ya là mais il ya
le même avec des ours un fossile donc
c'est tous la même espèce d'oursins
accumulé les uns sur les autres comme ça
l'est les pyramides les pyramides
d'égypte sont construites en calcaire
néolithique donc les limites ce sont des
petits voiliers c'est exactement ça ce
sont des petits forum en face aux sons
des gros foraminifères au moins pour
autant que les mammifères donc une faune
cette taille là à peu près et donc et
c'est foraminifères il se trouvant dans
les pyramides d'égypte sont construits
en roche qui sont fait à 100% de
foraminifères voilà de la roche comme ça
fait à 100% ne foraminifères cimenté
dans plus ou moins de sable voilà là
vous en avez un autre exemple magnifique
c'est quelqu'un hémolytique voilà le
calcaire du crétacé aussi donc crétacé
qui est formé de ces fameux
coccolithophores idée donc les
coccolithes
coccolithes vas-y fais péter les cocos
it à mardi à de célèbres comiques
séparables donc les calcaires du crétacé
voyez que vous voyez à être hôte a par
exemple elles sont formées d'assemblage
pareil complètement mono spécifique info
quasiment uniquement de c2c coccolithes
envoyé là que vous voyez là c'est
quasiment 100 % duco call it avec
quelques autres foraminifères ici et là
bas sinon c'est quasiment 100% du
coccolithes voilà les assemblages mono
spécifiques
ça existe avec zéro disparités bon
peut-être les coccolithes c'est pas le
meilleur exemple bien les inhumations
lesnums h elle donc si vous cherchez lui
machel sur internet
vous avez trouvé tomber sur des
assemblages de coquillages comme ça par
exemple
voilà ça c'est pareil a enfin je veux
dire il n'ya peut-être pas qu'une seule
espèce de coquillages mais il ya que du
coquillage à là dedans c'est que du
coquillage du bivalves et du gastéropode
et là bon quand un assemblage de
spécifique enfin cdd des roches dans
laquelle il ya zéro disparités et
beaucoup de des roches dans laquelle il
ya zéro disparités il en existait
beaucoup plus que tu n'imagines ou en
tout cas beaucoup plus que ce que lui
cela essaye de vous le faire croire
donc donc ce qu'ils disent est
totalement faux quand il dit que c'est
exactement ce qu'on retrouve dans le
registre fossile c'est totalement et
absolument faux le registre fossile est
bourré d'assemblage où il ya zéro
disparités la totalité du crétacé en
france et fait de roche forme est
presque uniquement de coccolithes veut
dire donc c'est un énorme assemblage
avec zéro disparités de dans quoi et
puis vous avez énormément de roche du
miocène aussi si vous vivez du côté de
bordeaux qui sont juste d'un brassage
gigantesque de de quelques échinodermes
de quelques espèces des teens au terme
de quelques espèces de de vival
enfin bref c'est un mix de très peu de
diversité mais non c'est un mix de très
peu de disparités au final c'est
beaucoup de coquillages avec beaucoup
par contre de diversité dedans donc ce
qui est en train de vous dire c'est même
totalement fausse et voilà sa prédiction
que le déluge devrait créer des éléments
très disparates
enfin des dépôts avec une très forte
disparité elle est en partant du
principe qu elle est vraie elle n'est
pas du tout vérifié par le registre
fossile pas du tout apprécié les way si
tu vas juste dans les schistes de
burgess ça marche dans les fils de murg
laisserai après si tu ignores la
totalité du reste du registre fossile
tout à l'heure il parle elle a dû
justement là au début du registre
fossile il disait au tout début il ya
des stromatolites bahia que des
stromatolites où sont les êtres humains
d'ailleurs à cet endroit là parce que si
les instruments reconnu le déluge c'est
qu'ils étaient l'arbre où ils sont les
êtres humains sans voix il y en a pas
justement là il est en train de dire
ouais exactement exactement là on est
typiquement dans le cas de citation de
stephen jay gould sortie de son contexte
stephen jay gould a effectivement décrit
le registre fossile comme étant bourré
de stase alors que normalement on
devrait voir des gens alors que si le
gradualisme fils éthique et est vrai on
devrait voir des changements graduels
dans le registre fossile donc qu'est ce
qu'a fait stephen jay gould il a proposé
la théorie des équilibres ponctué il n'a
pas proposé que le monde et avait été
créée en six jours par dieu et ensuite
balayé d'un revers de main avec un avec
un grand avec un une grande inondation
un grand déluge universel
donc voilà là là on est typiquement dans
un cas de flagrant délit de j'ai pris
stephen jay gould gelé sortie de son
contexte et je vous leur sert à la sauce
créationnistes on est en plein dedans ça
vient du même mec qui de diapos plutôt
nous montrer du gradualisme fils
éthiques
enfin nous montrer cette pardon nous
montrer cette image on voit des
équilibres ponctué qui explique comment
les stades parce que ça c'est une star
ici c'est un très droite là vous avez un
gradient morphologie de gauche à droite
donc ça c'est une stase dans le temps et
vous avez un fort sens morphologiques
une autre stade a forcément faux logique
une stase forcément logique in-stat sert
d' équilibre ça c'est les équilibres
ponctué donc le même mec qui vous a mis
cette photo là et qu'il ne comprend pas
visiblement lavours site stephen jay
gould plus tard pour vous dire que
la création que l'évolution n'est pas
vrai parce qu'on voit pas de gradualisme
bah oui mais c'est précisément ce que
stephen jay gould disais dans mon
registre fossile on voit pas le
gradualisme on voit des petits sauts des
petites phrases et stephen jay gould en
son article 2 71 où il décrit les
équilibres ponctuée pour la première
fois bah il décrit des trilobites qui
d'abord alors je crois qu'il avait
compté le nombre de facettes dans les
yeux des trilobites du dévonien
d'amérique du nord et donc de base en
rousse dans la stratigraphie il comptait
y en avait 16 puis 17 puis 18 puis 19 19
face est dans l'oeil de ces trilobites
donc il faisait 17 18 19 20 vaches à
lait pour lui c'était des sceaux
évolutif en réalité c'est un changement
graduel aussi du nombre
on peut aussi interpréter ça comme un
changement graduel du nombre de facettes
dans les yeux des trilobites mai mais
bon après ça c'est l'interprétation et
voilà donc le dire comment tu réconcilie
ça cette observation la 2 stephen jay
gould avec ton interprétation n'y a pas
de changement alors qu'on voit
littéralement le nombre de dos elle
changé dans le registre fossile augmenté
aller dans une direction particulière un
peu comme les belles flèches là que tu
nous a mis la voilà en train d'essayer
de nous faire croire qu'il y a pas
d'intermédiaire dans le registre fossile
archéoptéryx un archéoptéryx que quand
on trouve à ce que l'aide sans les
plumes on l'interprète comme un
dinosaure mais quand on se trouve à
squelette avec les plumes on interprète
comme un oiseau alors que c'est la même
espèce comment eliès qu'il peut être
plus trompe lui transitionnelle que ça
je veux dire sans les plumes c'est un
dinosaure avec les plus que c'est un
oiseau je veux dire que le squelette
d'un dinosaure avec les plumes d'un
oiseau ensemble et il n'y a pas de
formes transitionnelle dans le registre
fossile bande de chenu bah voyons donc
voilà il est en train de vous vendre
encore une fois sorti de contexte de
stephen jay gould
qui exprime est exactement tout le
contraire de ce qu'il est en train
d'expliquer ce qui ne marche pas par
exemple avec liste rose aux russes voilà
avec liste rose aux russes les premiers
liste rose au risque on trouve dans le
permis à son gros très gros
et puis après il ya deux espèces de
liste rose au risque donc à la
transition entre le permis à l trias
donc pendant la grande extinction de
masse il ya ce qu'on appelle l'effet
lilliput donc les listes roseaux russe
je vais vous mettre une petite illustre
aux russes parce que vous le savez
peut-être pas ce que c'est c'est vrai
que aller voilà donc liste rose aux
riches tiens on va prendre cette image
là parce qu'elle est
elle illustre très bien donc les listes
rose aux russes avant la limite permise
trias donc avant la grande extinction
permis atria celle qui a tué 90 % des
espèces liste rose aux russes étaient
très gros et après l'extinction d'istres
aux riches est tout petit voilà donc
c'est assez lisse trop rigide mackay
gaye et ça c'est liste rose russe mais
regagne donc ça c'est ce qui s'est passé
ça s'appelle l'effet lilliput donc les
espèces pendant les extinctions pendant
les événements destin actions deviennent
plus petits ça augmente leur leur
vitesse de reproduction
ce qui permet du coup d'augmenter les
chances de mutation et donc d'adaptation
et ça ça aussi ça diminue tout
simplement la quantité de bouche que
vous avez besoin pour vous arrivé à
l'âge de la maturité
donc c est aussi un avantage pendant
l'événement d'extinction bref dix roses
aux russes rétrécit si ce monsieur a
raison et qu'effectivement on observe
qu'une série de stase dans l'évolution
on devrait avoir la grosse espèce de
liste rose aux russes celle-là au
permien et tout de suite après la petite
espèce de liste rose russe au trias donc
on aurait 2 stase séparés par du rien
donc ce que stephen jay gould
interpréterait comme un équilibre
ponctué c'est à dire une évolution
soudaine est ce que lui interpréterait
comme un événement magique
guidés par un être surnaturel ou pas
juif c'est quoi
mais cela n'est pas le cas puisque liste
rose horus mât cay est lisse trop riche
mariage et bien il ya il y à des espèces
qui font un pont entre la taille de
liste rose aux riches makaga
ici est la taille de liste rose aux
riches broderies ici il ya deux espèces
curva tus et des clés vis donc qu'ils
sont de taille intermédiaire voilà voilà
donc non on ne voit pas de stage on voit
bien une transition des cures mathus qui
ont battu ce elle n'apparaît que pendant
la transition permien trias en plus non
seulement il est intermédiaire en taille
jusqu'à la limite on pourrait même
ignoré des clés vis mais on pourrait
juste ne retenir que relate us qui
apparaît uniquement pendant la limite
permise trias est intermédiaire en
taille et il est intermédiaire dans le
temps entre les deux donc ces genres
l'intermédiaire parfait voilà sur la
douce liste roseaux risquions lathus
parfait intermédiaire entre liste rose
auris macheda et du père via et liste
rose or historia et du trias donc jambes
allaient y voilà et j'aimerais bien
savoir comment il explique son silence
on danse on dans son petit univers dans
un petit univers à lui comment il a
essayé
est ce qu'il explique que les fossiles
soit encore ordonner de cette façon
aussi là parce que voilà mon bistrot
zaurus curva tus
enfin bon liste rose aux russes de
grande taille il vient avant mon liste
rose aux russes de petite taille et le
liste rose or de taille intermédiaire il
arrive entre les deux donc comment tu
expliques que ce soit dans ce cadre là
aussi pour alors que dans un déluge
dans l'hypothèse d'un déluge où tout
aurait été brassés du coup par le déluge
bah tout devrait se déposer de façon
désordonnée
donc pourquoi est-ce que donc la danse
on dans son petit monde fantaisiste à
lui on a le paléozoïque et le mésozoïque
qui correspondent au déluge pourquoi
est-ce qu'on retrouve des dinosaures et
des ammonites que au mésozoïque et
pourquoi on retrouve des tris
hobbit est d aider et qui ose t garde
que d art auxerre voilà que dans le
paléo zurich
pourquoi est-ce que le registre fossile
un ordre
pourquoi comment ça se fait qu'il ya
certains fossiles qu'on retrouve dans
certaines strates et pas d'autres
j'aimerais bien le savoir
alors vous pourriez faire l'hypothèse
que éventuellement quand tous et
redéposés à la fin du déluge les
éléments les plus lourds se sont
déposées au fond et les éléments les
plus légers se sont déposés au dessus
ben va falloir m'expliquer pourquoi les
dinosaures sont pas au fond parce que
les dinosaures ils sont mésozoïque donc
politiquement il sauve au dessus les
dinosaures étant les éléments les plus
lourds de cette histoire il aurait dû
finir au fond
or ils ne sont pas ils sont au dessus et
pendant ce temps là les éléments les
plus légers que sont les foraminifères
ils sont partout mais ça c'est pas
logique non plus c'est pas logique non
plus donc tout ça afin d'arriver à
l'expliquer avec ça dans sa fantaisie là
encore une demi heure 40 minutes pour y
arriver je pense que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure pour liste rose or et les
trilobites vous trouverez aussi de très
bons exemples chez les ammonites et chez
les foraminifères il ya de très très
beaux exemples de fera midi faire si
vous si vous recherchez
un mini ferrone évolution trouva aussi
de très bons exemples d'espèces
transitionnelle parmi les foraminifères
comme par exemple c'est celui-là voyait
celui là vous avez effectivement vous
avez une stase ici donc ici cet axe là
représente la forme de la coquille c'est
avec cela représente l'âge et donc vous
avez l'impression d'avoir une stase ici
dans la forme de la coquille
l'impression d'avoir une stase ici dans
la forme de la copie mais entre les deux
il ya une évolution rapide
voilà donc quand on s'intéresse aux
détails voyez on la voit l'évolution
rapide mais bon faut s'intéresser au
détail évidemment faux pas est très
compact faut pas être incluses
pourquoi un événement d'inondations
déposerait trois fois le même chien
comment par quelle magie c'est là là
c'est pas c'est comment disait tout à
l'heure m
lebon créationnistes le mauvais
créationnisme
le créationnisme avec les bons arguments
et c'est quoi cet argument de merde là
si le création si le déluge il prend des
chiens et bien il va déposer les mêmes
chiens sur trois niveaux différents
un bon trois niveaux différents avec un
dé lui mais comment comment tu crées
trois niveaux différents avec un déluge
sauf quand on voit pas non ce n'est pas
un global life assemblée de gens c'est à
dire que si l'hypothèse du déluge
biblique et est vrai tout depuis le
cambria ici jusqu'à la fin du mésozoïque
ici jusqu'à l'extinction des dinosaures
les phone devrait être absolument
homogène c'est ce qu'il appelle un
assemblage de la vie mondiale les phone
devrait être absolument homogène
or c'est pas vrai en bas ici vous
trouvez que des trilobites enfin vous ne
trouverez des trilobites que en bas dans
ce qu'on appelle le paléozoïque et vous
ne trouverez des ammonites et des
dinosaures que dans la partie haute
qu'on appelle le mésozoïque vous ne
trouverez de tetra chorale hier que dans
la partie inférieure
et vous ne trouverez d'exa chorale hier
que dans la partie supérieure dans la
partie inférieure vous aurez les
brachiopodes qui seront les bivalves
dominant dans la partie supérieure ce
seront les mollusques qui seront les
bivalves dominant bref
les observations de terrain les seuls
qui conte les fai vont à l'encontre de
cet assemblage mondiale de la vie la
comédie c'est exactement contraire et
sans compter le nombre de fois où on
observe du gradualisme génétique parce
que évidemment j'ai pas gradualisme
d'éthique fait les ti glas du balisage
genre ni d'écrire mais bref tout 100 à
120 internet comprendra quand même il y
à toutes les fois où on observe du
gradualisme politique comme par exemple
alors je suis pas sûr de se battre ça
s'applique alors on va peut-être prendre
un exemple c'est un peu plus évident
évidemment vous avez que des trucs d
exemple théorique mais la voilà par
exemple des foraminifères en nage ici et
on croit que c'est normalement la et
donc l'enroulement de la coquille voyez
il ya des changements lieux d'enrôlement
de la coquille qui sont graduelles dans
le temps voilà donc il ya aussi des
exemples de gradualisme dans le registre
fossile inexplicable du coup par le
absolument inexplicable par un une
inondation soudaine et un enterrement
soudain deux des organismes et tout ça
c'est ça c'est publié dans pays et
n'ayez donc ses bourreaux journal gros
journal de scientifiques preview
d'enfants comité de lecture tout ça tout
ça et ça m'a pris 40 secondes on se
trouve et c'est surtout cela qui est
désolant c'est que ça me rend 40
secondes pour des zones kessé truc c'est
même pas intéressant qui m'a envoyé
cette vidéo pour essayer de me faire
croire que c'était intéressant que les
mails pas intéressant pour la il
persiste dans son délire alors je n'ai
pas la même chose
c'est marrant parce qu'il dit on a des
preuves de catastrophes tu ne les as pas
montré toujours pas le diable le seul le
seul dépôt catastrophique qu'on a vu
c'est un peu dingue et c'est moi qui
voulais montrer la preuve de son courant
est ouest c'était que l'on trouve des
coraux
c'était qu'on trouve des coraux dans les
latitudes les latitudes tropicales
je vois pas ça comme une preuve de
courage et ouest est maintenant sa
nouvelle preuve c'est qu'on retrouve le
même bio méchant tio nez partout dans le
mésozoïque et dans le paléozoïque ce qui
est totalement faux
ce qui est là je veux dire la raison
fondamentale pour laquelle on appelle le
paléozoïque le paléozoïque et le
mésozoïque le mésozoïque c'est justement
parce que les phones sont différentes
entre les deux parce qu'il ya une
extinction de masse entre les deux la
fameuse extinction permien trias donc
les feux ne sont pas du tout homogène
entre le paléozoïque et le mésozoïque
c'est précisément pour ça qu'on leur a
donné des noms différents
voilà donc il faut nier le dire de leila
on est sûr de la négation pure et dure
des données accumulées depuis depuis que
la géologie existe avant même que la
géologie
avant même que la théorie de l'évolution
ne soit mise en place un jeu dire la
géologie est une discipline bien plus
vieille que la théorie de l'évolution
et là il faut s'asseoir dessus mais
comme il faut même le principe d'
actualiser
comme je disais tout à l'heure donc
aucune des preuves dont il nous parle là
sur samedi à pau nous a présenté aucune
des preuves qu'il nous remontre un arbre
phylogénétique donc un arbre un arbre
phylogénétique par définition implique
qu'il y a de l'évolution c'est à dire
que s'il n'y avait pas d'évolution on
n'aurait pas un arbre phylogénétique
avec des branchements successifs donc
des ancêtres en commun
on aurait un râteau on aurait un râteau
ou un peigne si vous voulez sans
évolution il n'y a pas d'arbres
phylogénétique parce que dans un arbre
phylogénétique il ya forcément tout ça
là tous et tous ses embranchements ce
sont des ancêtres en commun et donc la
longueur de branche
c'est de l'évolution donc si vous
admettez l'existence d'un arbre
phylogénétique vous admettez forcément
l'existence de l'évolution s'il n'y
avait pas d'évolution l'arbre film
n'existerait pas et ça ressemblerait un
peigne voyez une ligne comme ça avec les
dents qui partent ou un râteau voilà
donc le simple fait qu'ils vous montre
cet arbre phylogénétique et qui va se
mettre à discuter dessus ça
alors à moins que ce soit pour le
contraste et après avec un peigne
justement mais alors dans ce cas là il
faut il va falloir là il vient de passer
une demi-heure agnel et l'existence même
de la géologie de la gravité à ce niveau
là je veux dire c'est à dire à ce niveau
là il faut il faut nier l'existence de
la gravité même parce que je viens comme
je disais à l'existence d'un déluge
implique forcément qui a eu de la très
haute énergie
donc il ya beaucoup d'eau qui se
déplacer beaucoup d'eau qui se déplace
sa bouche des gros rochers donc s'il y
avait eu l'existence d'un déluge va vous
auriez une dépôt géologique avec des
gros rochers en bas des rochers moyens
et puis après du sable et puis après de
l'argile
voilà parce que la gravité et ce dépôt
n'existe pas et pour nier l'existence de
ce dépôt bas il faut nier la gravité et
c'est ce qu'il est en train de finir si
vous admettez qu'un poudingue peut se
développer
enfin si vous admettez que le déluge
biblique a pu conduire à une condition
ou un pou d'agde s'est retrouvé au
dessus de au dessus du sable c'est que
vous nier l'existence de la gravité il
ya qu un seul moyen d'expliquer que le
sable se trouve en dessous du poudingue
sait qui a d'abord regardé peau de sable
le sable s'est durcie puis il ya eu un
dépôt de poudingue mais ça veut ça veut
dire que l'eau est venue 2
donc pas un déluge biblique bref où
vas-tu avec ce tarif il est là il va
falloir qu'il n'y l'adn servier
l'existant cadre qu'il faut qu'en plus
cela il faut oublier que l'adn
n'existait que l'ag en se structurant
fans soit financée grâce aux médicaments
c'est un mensonge
c'est encore une fois c'est un mensonge
ou une grosse erreur
à savoir que le on n'a pas besoin des
fossiles pour créer des arbres
phylogénétiques surtout là j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il y ait réellement de
d'éléments fossiles c'est que des
bactéries en plus alors donc là c'est un
arbre phylogénétique de bactéries dont
il ya aucune chance que cet arbre
phylogénétique et été générés à partir
de données issues des fossiles c'est
forcément des données issues de l'adn
donc il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un fossile
dans cet arbre phylogénétique c'est ça
que j'ai essayé de vous dire là il n'y a
pas l'ombre d'un fossile donc tout ce
qui vient de vous dire là sur l'arbre
phylogénétique ça reflète l'ordre dans
lequel les fossiles se diversifient
machin tout ça ça ne s'applique pas à
l'arbre qu'il vous montre ici
voilà le mec est tellement ou fraise
avec ce qui vous racontent qui n'est pas
capable de l'illustré avec le bon arbre
donc ça c'est un arbre qui a été générée
par des données adn
et si on veut nier l'existence de cet
arbre il faut nier que
l'existence de l'adn voilà c'est tout
l'adn n'a pas une structure aléatoire
l'adn à une structure et cette structure
reflètent les différents événements de
spéciation qui ont eu lieu durant la
longue histoire évolutive des organismes
sur terre et quelques transfert
horizontal à cet homme est un menteur
cet homme est un menteur si c'est lui
qui a créé cet arbre évolutive le dira
le mec le mec se présente comme un
géologue
voilà qui va nous faire la paléontologie
du déluge et nous montre un arbre où il
ya zéro données paléontologiques dans le
tas je les 10 et des bactéries tout ça
il ya zéro données paléontologiques sur
les bactéries qui peuvent être utilisées
pour faire un arbre phylogénétique cet
homme est un menteur c'est toujours des
bactéries ça y est avec les animaux
éventuellement là il peut faire des
trucs arrière de paléontologie
enfin nous dire c'est que normalement
les branches les plus banales devrait
nous donner les premiers fossiles
si et seulement si le registre fossile
et complet ce qui ne l'est pas le
registre fossile devient des sens
uniquement à partir de 550 millions
d'années c'est à dire au début du
cambrien avant ça le registre fossile il
est quasiment vide donc donc on n'a pas
trop idée de ce qui se passe avant ça
mais après dans les grandes lignes on
voit dans les grandes lignes on voit
effectivement apparaître les arcs et
aussi hâte avant les apparaître les arcs
et aussi hâte avant les mollusques dans
les grandes lignes les taxons les plus
primitifs apparaissent avant les taxant
les plus évolués on voit pas par exemple
de tétrapodes apparaître avant les
premiers poissons et on voit pas les
premiers dinosaures à paraître avant les
premiers reptiles et on voit pas les
premiers mammifères apparaître après des
premiers humains par exemple voient
plutôt dire ça dans le sens on voit pas
les premiers humains à paraître avant
les premiers mammifères dans les grandes
lignes
si le registre fossile suis l'arbre de
la vie après si on commence
effectivement à fouiller les détails bah
oui il ya des petites incohérences mais
enfin ces petites incohérences
elles sont essentiellement dues au fait
que le registre fossile n'est absolument
pas parfait et qui a juste pas assez de
paléontologues dans le monde pour
chercher toutes les roches du monde et
que de toute façon toutes les roches du
monde ne représente pas toute l'histoire
de la vie faut aussi se dire que dans
l'absolu 99% des roches de la planète
terre sont inaccessibles à l'être humain
faut pas oublier ça non plus
donc donc c'est même pas dit que la
totalité du registre fossile accessible
à l'être humain soit capable de
représenter la totalité de l'histoire de
la vie donc donc donc il est en train de
partir s'il va vraiment dans la
direction que je crois qu'il va aller
maintenant
bah ouais c'est extrêmement malhonnête
c'est extrêmement malhonnête c'est pas
faux dans l'absolu mais c'est
extrêmement malhonnête
les cyanobactéries comme j'ai dit ah on
n'a pas les cyanobactéries en premier et
puis après on allait les premiers
organismes simple après les premiers
organismes habilités rien les premières
plantes
après on a eu seulement les premiers
invertébrés les premiers points des
premiers reptiles
moi aussi je peux me faire déchirer
intéressant donc il parle de la
transition
l'adaptation à la vie terrestre qui
effectivement est bien documenté donc
jusqu'au fossiles est bien trop
clairement une tendance
la sortie de l'eau ce qui va à
l'encontre totalement
[Rires]
donc le mec il essaye de nous faire
croire qu'en fait c'est l'eau du déluge
qui en montant à déposer mais il est con
mais il est con il est con pour deux
raisons la première c'est que on est
tout à fait enfin la raison pour
laquelle on parle d'une transition de
l'eau vers la terre chez les plantes
comme chez les animaux c'est d'une parce
qu'on voit les adaptations à la vie
terrestre se développer donc notamment
chez les vaches et les animaux
terrestres vous voyez le développement
d'un dut membres qui riediens voilà donc
la transformation de la nageoire en une
pâte
donc c'est ça rien à voir avec
l'environnement dans lequel l'animal a
été déposé donc donc rien à voir avec la
flotte dont il nous parle là donc ce
qu'on voit pas c'est pas on voit pas
seulement parce qu'il a l'air de
suggérer c'est qu'en gros ce que les
paléontologues interprète comme la
sortie des eaux en fait c'est un poisson
qui a d'abord été des pauses qui au
début du déluge a été déposée dans l'eau
puis en fait au fur et à mesure que
l'eau du déluge montée il a été déposée
de plus en plus haut de telle sorte
qu'on croit que le même poisson je le
même poisson a vécu sur terre mais t'es
con parce que dans nos allées tout le
temps là donc ton milieu de dépôt il est
toujours marin et puis c'est toujours le
même poisson
or c'est pas le même poisson en bataller
tu as des poissons aux poissons et puis
en ôta des poissons à nageoires charnues
et puis encore en hôtel et poissons avec
un bras qu'on appelle des tétrapodes
donc
donc c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
d'une et de deux
c'est toujours un milieu marin dans ton
idée alors qu'à au final au bout d'un
moment les poissons ils sont en milieu
terrestre alors que ton des pôles
assistons aussi ensuite à théorie du
déluge à la crau c'est le dépôt le
milieu de dépôt il est censé être
toujours marin donc on n'est pas censé
voir de sortie des eaux dans ton modèle
c'est là où je veux en venir c'est que
si on suit le modèle du déluge des arts
n'est pas censé voir de sortie des eaux
puisque tous et déposés dans l'eau donc
tous les milieux de dépôt sont sous
l'eau c'est exactement ce que je disais
au début quand je parlais des calcaires
lacustre un don camillo d'eau douce puis
que je parlais des des cracks
vous voyez de vous rappeler les cracks
due à la sécheresse la les craquelures
due à la sécheresse ça c'est pareil ça
c'est pas fait sous l'eau ça
voilà maintenant dans un modèle où tous
les fossiles ont été formés par le
déluge va tout doit être déposée sous de
l'eau de mer dans des milieux marins
or les géologues savent très bien
identifier les milieux marins donc bref
dont c'est un groupe c'est un gros mytho
là ce qui vient de vous faire clairement
s'il avait raison bas ce serait le même
poids sont développées dans un milieu
marin puis un milieu terrestre
or c'est pas le même poisson parce que
il a développé un bras et c'est pas un
milieu terrestre de toute façon puisque
dans son modèle c'est toujours déposer
sous l'eau voilà donc il a tort sur les
deux points alexis rastier je me sens
des magnolias les ans j'espère dans les
prochains plus reconnue
non quand même mal comment il va s'en
sortir du coup là il entend dire que ça
marche pas avec les animaux votre n8
mais ça marche avec les plantes dont je
me demande comment il va s'en sortir du
coup
project là il nous dit que l'ordre
phylogénétique suit l'ordre de la triste
réalité ce qui est normal puisqu'on
parle d'une transition depuis des
plantes aquatiques jusqu'à des plantes
devenu terrestre donc même si même si la
méthode est pas hyper clean je n'ai pas
de m'attarder dessus puisque
fondamentalement je suis pas contre ce
qu'ils ont à me dire
je me demande juste ouest qu'il va
arriver c'est à dire que la sq il en
train de nous dire c'est que
effectivement les i
l'ordre de la phylogénie l'ordre prédit
par l'évolution est aussi nombre que tu
peux voir plus ou moins si tu vas sur le
bord d'un lac
c'est à dire que les plantes les plus
primitifs sont aussi celles qui ont
besoin
dos les plantes les plus des arrivées
sont celles qui ont besoin de moins
d'eau bon admettons
on va dire on va dire que ça c'est
correct c'est grosso modo correct voilà
on va dire que c'est grosso merdo
correct on va pas remettre ça en
question mais je me demande d'où il va
en fait avec ça à la limite tu viens de
dire ok l'ordre évolutif peut-être un
peu influé par l'écologie admettons mais
en quoi ça comment est-ce qu ensuite il
va arriver à nous expliquer dans quel
ordre
comment est-ce qu'il va réussir ensuite
à nous expliquer que le que le que le
déluge a enterré les plantes dans le bon
ordre
ça par contre ça me par contre je ne
peux thèse au sein d' hypothèse c'est
qu'il ya un énorme continent je ferai de
la taille d'un continent qui flotte sur
l'eau à essence mais ne s'est pas du
tout d'hypothèses ça c'est un sens
inverse un délire
[Rires]
donc son hypothèse c'est que donc son
hypothèse pour expliquer c'est que donc
vous aviez un pseudo continent flottant
1 sur l'eau qui existait avant le déluge
de la taille d'un continent avec les
espèces les plus dépendantes de l'eau à
l'extérieur les espèces les moins
dépendantes de l'eau à l'intérieur et
que ce continent flottant qui vivait sa
meilleure vie avant le déluge a commencé
à ce à commencer à se disloquer de
l'intérieur vers l'extérieur pendant les
luges pas avant pas prêt pendant le
déluge uniquement en vertu de quoi tu
sais pas
c'est même pas une hypothèse c'est même
pas une hypothèse c'est une blague
c'est une blague est là je commence à me
demander si c'est pas un troll je suis
en train de me demander si ça fait pas
quarante minutes que je m'acharne sur un
troll en fait parce que vraiment ça
c'est pas une hypothèse tu fais de la
merde c'est pas une hypothèse mon chéri
c'est de la merde qu'est ce que quoi
quoi c'est n'importe quoi
mais comment tu veux vous dire ça peut
pas être sérieux bon bah les milliards
les millions de milliards de raisons
pour laquelle ça marcherait pas ben je
sais pas moi peut-être déjà parce que un
continent enfin je veux dire d'où vient
l'eau douce qui alimente la forêt voilà
pour commencer je veux dire si c'est si
c'est un genre de tourbières flottante
comme tu dis là d'où vient l'eau douce
parce que la tombe ya flottante qui lui
a inspiré ce modèle elle était sur un
lac d'eau douce mais là on parle de la
d'une tourbière flottante de la taille
d'un continent dans l'eau dans l'eau de
mer
d'où vient l'eau douce de la pluie bah
ouais mais
nu par quoi puisque c'est juste une
tourbière flottante en forêt qu'il pleut
constamment de suba enfin bref
et puis bah de toute façon encore une
fois la formation spécimens bridge dont
j'ai parlé au début il ya 27 niveaux de
forêt empilés les uns sur les autres
avec les racines bien implantée dans un
sol un vrai sol pas une tourbière
flottante
comment tu expliques une telle formation
parce que des petits bouts de tourbières
là qui se décroche et se développe et se
déposent 27 fois les unes sur les autres
pendant le déluge
bah ça ça crée pas un seul je veux dire
là on a des racines vraiment implanté
dans du sol et on sait faire la
différence entre du sable et de la
tourbière
je veux dire les géologues sont pas
crétin ils savent faire la différence
entre de la tourbière il reste donc si
c'était de la tourbière on l'aurait su
donc non donc non absolument pas surtout
pas et mêmes et pour terminer c'est que
même avec une forêt flottante de la
taille d'un continent
tu crées pas la totalité des des forêts
fossiles qu'on a dans le monde puisque
la totalité des forêts fossiles qu'on a
dans le monde c'est juste gigantesque
veut dire déjà une flore et flottante de
la taille d'un continent ça suffirait
même pas alimenter le bassin minier du
nord de l'europe quoi donc nord de la
france angleterre et tout jusqu'à la
bohème john toutes les tout ce qui a de
tous les grands bassins miniers l'a donc
jusqu'à la pologne quoi qui est déjà
plus ou moins de la taille d'un
continent du coup c'est rien que ce
bassin minier là je veux dire vous avez
une forêt de la taille d'un continent
mais en plus sur plusieurs niveaux
et puis bon encore une fois ça ne fait
que représenter les grands enfin je veux
dire c'est cette histoire là c'est pour
expliquer l'évolution des plantes
enfin c'est une alternative pour
expliquer les volumes
des plantes dans les grandes lignes mais
enfin dans l'absolu ça voudrait dire que
sur la fin vous auriez juste de la forêt
or le problème c'est qu'il ya toujours
des fougères dans le registre fossile à
ce niveau là et il ya toujours des
mousses et il ya toujours des décors des
carriers office et et il ya toujours
donc ce modèle là il explique pas
pourquoi on trouve encore des dépôts de
plantes adaptées fortement à l'eau même
une fois qu'on a encore des forêts
normalement une fois que ton continent
il est érodée au niveau forêt il n'ya
plus que de la forêt qui se dépose or
arrivé au moment des forêts c'est le
carbonifère carbonifère on a déjà les
premières forêt on a aussi et j'ai
presque envie de dire surtout des
plantes adaptées à un environnement de
très très fortement aquatique puisque
c'est du marécage quoi donc
donc c'est des conneries tout ça c'est
des conneries maintenant c'est d'un
niveau intergalactique mans ne m'apporte
quoi c'est à dire ça lui a quand même
pris dix grosses minutes pour en arriver
là pour nous expliquer sa théorie
bullshit jeudi et puis encore une fois
la gravité et au bout la gravité elle
peut aller se faire [ __ ] la physique
aussi jeune nathan lecompte faisait le
reste est tellement content ils avaient
des complices sur le jeu
en plus il parle de vieilles roches
noires le vieille roche le met et
créationnisme et veut bien admettre que
les heroes le mec n'arrive même pas à
expliquer son demir sans se contredire
il n'y aurait bien les montagnes à
l'arrière qui pourrait ramener de l'eau
dont les biens pour l'écouter c'est
surtout ça qui soit non parce que
l'effort et du carbonifère ou toute
l'excellence justement des plantes les
plus adaptées au losc on plante moins
adapté à l'eau alors que dans son
système à lui les plans on aurait plus
que des plantes pas adaptés à lure c'est
ça qu'il faut en fait dans son dans son
truc c'est que ok la torre des plantes
essentiellement adapté à nos mais la
torre plus de plantes adaptées à l'eau
donc ça c'est faux c'est pas ça que ça
ressemblerait ça ressemblerait à une
forêt bien sèche à ce niveau log
il y aurait plus d'eau c'est bien ça
qu'il faut dans son modèle c'est que là
c'est un énorme mensonge ou parce que là
dans cette forêt du carbonifère vous
avez l'eau au milieu les plantes les
plus adaptées à l'eau sur le bord de
l'eau et les plantes les moins adaptés à
nos loin de l'eau pour ça que c'est con
comme système n'explique rien du tout
[Musique]
cros et l'ex ce que la théorie de
l'évolution expliquent aussi très bien
au début les plantes n'avaient pas de
système vasculaire ou pas un système
vasculaire rigide donc elle ne pouvait
pas grandir et après quand le système
bascule et rigide a évolué alors elle
pouvait grandir et ensuite elles ont
évolué la lignine et là elle pouvait
devenir des arbres voilà l'évolution
explique ça bien mieux beaucoup mieux en
réalité j'ai une meilleure question mais
avec toutes nos salles et qui a
recouvert le monde pendant le grand
déluge
comment la moindre plante a pu survivre
airs grandir après le déluge
vous avez deux heures ah ben ça alors je
croyais que noé avait sauvé un couple de
chaque être vivant avant que les animaux
à merde ça allait bien qu on oublié un
truc
ce genre même s'il avait sauvé des
graines je veux dire déjà toutes les
plantes n'ont pas traîné ses dunes et de
2nde de toute façon le sol a été salée
partout rien je veux dire vous regardez
les chercher des images de valen skelton
de aussi ça alors une carcasse de
baleine sous l'eau dire casse de baleine
sous l'eau voilà bah si les fossiles il
sera bien au fond de l'eau et puis il se
dépose et puis il se finisse recouvert
ou non fall et les organismes finistre
couverts ou non s'ils sont recouverts il
faut signer s'ils ne le sont pas et
c'est négliger effectivement que les sur
terre vous avez des événements qui
s'appelle des flashs flotte donc des
inondations rapide parce que c'est pas
parce que je sais pas parce que je suis
contrôlé luge que je suis pas pour les
inondations une fois de temps en temps
je lire des inondations à et chez le
classique y en a eu
ça amène beaucoup de boue et ça recouvre
une bonne partie de votre forêt et puis
ben voilà votre forêt se retrouvent
intérêt au moins toutes les branches les
arbres les machins tout ce qui était au
sol ça se retrouve enterré donc vous
n'avez même pas forcément besoin d'aller
dans l'eau jusque dans les océans
il a su s'il a aimé toutes les forêts
sont pas trouvées dans des roches marié
enfin les dépôts les dépôts de charbon
qui sont effectivement dans le nord de
l'europe sont des dépôts qui sont des
alternances entre des marécages et du
milieu marin oui mais bon si vous prenez
les bassins les bassins miniers qui sont
à saint-etienne par exemple et dans la
région de saint-etienne
il ya zéro roche marina là bas rhin
donc non ça marche pas ton explication
pour tous les babas ce que je dis son
explication marche pas dès que vous avez
un environnement qui est pas marin donc
un environnement soit continental soit
l'environnement lacustre voilà tous les
arbres qu'on trouve carbonifère ne sont
pas creux d'une et de deux c'est juste
la lignine qui est beaucoup plus dure
autour queue leu leu pas enfin que que
les tissus qui sont à l'intérieur c'est
tout alain terrien c'est que du tissus
vasculaires c'est de la cellulose s'est
pas spécialement hyper ligneux donc ça
peut se décomposer et ça se décompose
plus rapidement que la ligne qui est
autour donc la ligne n elle a plus de
chance de se retrouver fossilisés que
les tissus mous à l'intérieur
ya rien d inexplicable parce qu'elle
n'ait pas cru quand elle pousse elle se
creuse à présent la qualité se forme
après quelques essais enfin que l'espace
a été cédée buisson s'est dévissée ce
qu'ils disent éléments là on est sur un
cas très particulier ne comprends pas
voilà il est clairement en dehors avec
les déjà ses arguments sur la partie
géologique est pas brillante mais
envoyait qu'il avait une idée les chiens
raconte m
sur les pentes
il est clairement quand il faut investir
et picking c'est à dire qu'il est à la
recherche d'une théorie de quelqu'un
d'autre qui va à peu près dans le sens
de cette quasi démarche classique de
quelqu'un qui cherche à prouver qu'il a
raison aux liens de savoir s'il a raison
c'est une protestation cherché à prouver
qu'on a raison et chercher à savoir si
on a raison c'est la très très grosse
distinction et là il essaye clairement
de prouver qu'il a raison et il fait un
argument d'autorité en cherchant
quelqu'un d'autre comme sachant que
celle des plantes qui ai grandi c'est de
toute façon très très marécageux n'a par
contre j'ai une vague idée le oui va
avec ça il va vraiment qu'il est
vraiment en train de nous sortir le
petit manuel du créationnistes et le
dépôt des chardons c'est typiquement ce
qu'on rencontre dans le nord de la
france voilà donc vous avez des niveaux
gréseux qui sont des innovations marine
des transgressions qui viennent
recouvrir le bassin minier
et puis ça permet de préserver les
couches marneuses et puis le la mer se
retire donc régression marine est à
nouveau un nouveau marais se développe
bon jusque lundi jusque là y'a rien de
ce qu'il dit j'espère que vous avez un
dénouement à notre histoire parce que
pour l'instant l'intro et les comics 1
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'expert soit décrit tout à l'heure que
il ya une grosse contradiction en fait
donc je crois qu'il est en train de
charger son argument là ça y est là le
bayer dans lequel on met tout à l'heure
tu nous a dit que les marécages c'était
des endroits où il y avait peu d'oxygène
et donc la décomposition elle est très
lentement
ben donc on peut trouver des gros
morceaux dans les marais d'après ce que
tu nous a décrit plutôt ce avec quoi je
suis d'accord après je suis d'accord que
autour des racines il va y avoir
effectivement la décomposition qui
devrait avoir lieu autour des racines
parce qu'autour des racing on n'est plus
tellement dans le marais et on est déjà
un peu plus sur du terrestre et un peu
moins sur du marécage dans le marais lui
même va y avoir des gros morceaux qui
pourront qui pourront se préserver
je pense que ça va être son argument oui
parce que tu l'as dit tout à l'heure
c'est pas des racines c'est des reason
et que les rhizomes ils descendent pas
en profondeur c'est tout bah y'a rien de
surnaturel là dedans mais bon ce n'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe
la raison pour laquelle s'est placé
parce que ça a été compressé c'est tout
moi je sais pas quel genre de crétins
était son professeur ou bien si c'est
lui qui est en train de mentir sur les
qualités
sur les réelles qualités de son
professeur mais non non c'est pour un
ouragan qui a créé le plat comme ça non
ceci dit tu sais ce qui tu sais quel
autre événement ne créerait pas à fond
plat mais au contraire des grosses des
grosses figures d'érosion une inondation
une grosse inondation de type d'élu
voilà donc non assez plat parce que
c'est compressé et puis ce qui a
recouvert le ski a recouvert le marais
c'est de l'eau de mer avec l'eau de mer
a déposé des grès légré complètement
compressé et je veux dire la plupart des
couches sont plates ça que je comprends
pas en fait dans son histoire de passer
très très plat le fonds est plat le
coucher plate le briquet plat tout est
très très plat bah ouais m'enfin quand
vous regardez la plupart des couches
sédimentaires sont plates
donc faut vraiment qu'il se passe un
truc justement pour que les couches
populaires
donc c'est ça que je comprends pas en
fait d'ailleurs il suffit d'une érosion
généralement ce qui va te rendes une
surface bien plate
ça va être un événement d'érosion et là
on parle de couches donc les couches de
charbon c'est quand même des milieux qui
sont exposées à l'air donc c'est quand
même des milieux très susceptible rose
donc rien des perturbations y a pas de
quoi être persuadé qu'il va nous
raconter sa life sur le dragon mais bon
c'est déjà pour agresser fois qu'ils 35
souffle que 13 buts plus que 13 minutes
raconte nous ton histoire nouragues on
part en 13 minutes parce que de toute
façon on sait déjà que c'est de la merde
donc c'est bon on sait déjà que c'est
pas un ouragan qui a retiré le charbon
c'est bon allez
l'espoir des sabres empilés les uns sur
les autres c'est plate mais ça va pas
fort mais de la roche c'est encore une
fois il s'appelle l'érosion son problème
le racing se résout tout seul il a dit
tout à l'heure que les racines
s'enfoncent pas dans l'argile je
comprends pas je comprends pas ce qu'il
dit le monsieur il dit des trucs il se
contredit après
ça ce sont les surfaces planes c'est de
l'érosion voilà c'est tout
cherche des palais au sol et là tu
sauras ce que de quoi tu parles
c'est lé palais au sol que tu veux la la
torah le truc en place mais tant que tu
me parles pas de palais au sol je vois
même pas pourquoi je t'écoute
ce qui explique la ce et le
principalement grevé et des mangroves
facile on en arrive par exemple en
egypte on sait à quoi ça ressemble aussi
et c'est pas ça que ça ressemble mais
j'arrête plus la vidéo parce que j'ai
envie de faire un saut voilà une
réflexion
qui est le charbon sur le site kentucky
12 ça expliquera toujours pas ça
explique toujours pas le site de
spécimens bridge que je vous ai montré
au début de la vidéo ou là on a des
bonnes grosses racines qui s'enfonce
bien profond dans le sol et bien
fossilisés sur 27 étages insiste bien
sur le fait qu'il a eu un doctorat
argument d'autorité
maintenant on compare la formation du
charbon avec les soja du maïs sainte
hélène est un événement extrêmement
typique bien c'est tout un système la
ville en train de nous expliquer darwin
chorizo ça marche pas pour tous les
goûts tous les exemples de forêt
pétrifiée qu'on connaît
il ya tellement d'endroits où vous
prenez des exemples de forêt pétrifiée
où les arbres sont encore en place
notamment notamment heinrich spécimens
bridge je dirais encore quand tu quand
on trouve des exemples de forêt
pétrifiée où les arbres sont tombés au
sol comme ça coûte ça c'est cohérent
avec le avec un déluge universel mais
par contre quand les arbres sont debout
encore comment vous expliquez ça et il y
en a tellement
voilà comme ça par exemple comment vous
l'expliquez ça c'est normalement un
délit l'universel ça balaye tout quoi
surtout que c'est le déluge universel il
est il a duré que quarante jours et
quarante nuits que c'est censé tout
balayé alors pourquoi pourquoi il ya
encore des arbres debout
encore une fois haute énergie tout ça
tout ça on s'en fout et puis que son
système explique pas du tout comment on
finit avec des arbres debout avec encore
des racines en plaçant son système de
forêt flotter là ils marchent pas du
tout je sens que ça a été ne serait très
longue explication juste pour vous dire
vous voyez mon modèle de forêt flottante
qui marche mais il est encore en train
d'essayer qu'il a prises ont trouvé
qu'il a raison au lieu de faire savoir
c'est la règle c'est embarrassant à
regarder je suis pas tant je suis pas
temps pressé de finir parce que c'est
douloureux et que si tu finir parce que
c'est embarrassant de la regarder
il est tellement il est tellement en
train de se dépatouiller dans sa
détermination d'essayer de se
dépatouiller dans sagan ou là on à
servir messi mais regardez mon modèle
qui marche si l'on prend tel angle de
vue tout ça c'est pas parce que ton
anglais dimache sur sa de surface que ça
marchera t enchères
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche la vie
non c'est bien ça le truc c'est qu'on ne
peut pas étendre ton modèle à plus loin
que kentucky 12
est ce que je veux dire je connais pas
le site de kentucky 12 alors on va
partir du principe que ton scientifique
créationnistes steve austin un raison
mettons voilà de ton modèle il s'arrête
aux premiers arbres debout
ce modèle s'arrête aux premiers arbres
debout et dieu sait que dans les dépôts
de charbon il y en a beaucoup
le premier arbre debout que tu croises
ton modèle marche plus à manger ça veut
dire qu'il était dans le sol ça veut
dire qu'il sait pas s'ils lisent et on
est encore dans le sol c'est juste parce
que les c'est juste parce que les
bassins miniers ne sont pas infinies je
veux dire ça minier il est sur un
continent et le continent il a une
limite cette limite c'est la meilleure
donc c'est normal qu'en suivant la
couche de charbon au bout d'un moment tu
finis sur une zone marine parce que je
veux dire les continents sont pas
infinies on a tenté des couches du
carbonifère au carbone 14
[Musique]
vous croyez encore ceux à sept minutes
de la fin
sept minutes de la fin et je t'aurais
juste trouver ennuyant à mourir mais on
adapte et du charbon du carbonifère avec
du carbone 14 le carbone 14 ne peut pas
datées quelque chose qui à plus de 50
milles ans le carbonifère sa 300
millions d'années
ça a plus de 300 millions d'années le
charbon lui même je crois les couches à
charbon elle en 320 je crois à 320 à 340
millions d'années au carbonifère qu'est
ce que tu espères dater au carbone 14
alors oui j'essaie alors ouais c'est
parce qu'on n'a jamais essayé de dater
au carbone 14 alors regardez là ils ont
tâté leur mère de carbone 14
et qu'est ce qu'ils trouvent abbas a
alors ils trouvent des âges random
complètement random ils trouvent que
leurs couches de charbon il n'y a pas
deux fois où elles ont même à j 1 c'est
bizarre ça quand même
c'est bizarre que toutes ces couches de
charbon est pas le même âge alors
qu'elles sont du même âge voilà donc
quand vous date est un objet qui n'est
qu'il ya plus de cinquante mille ans au
carbone 14 vous trouvez des âges
aléatoire parce que bâle le carbone 14
quand même et si tu vas quand même
trouvé des molécules enfin des molécules
des atomes de carbone et 20 quand même
vous renvoyer à un âge mais seulement 7
h sur un faux parce que au delà je veux
dire c'est là pour pour dater on va dire
ça autrement pour dater des roches du
carbonifère au carbone 14
il faut nier tout ce qu'on sait de la
physique nucléaire
voilà et avec la physique nucléaire ont
produit de l'électricité donc on connait
bien quand même comment ça marche la
physique nucléaire
je veux dire une bonne partie de notre
économie qui est basé là dessus
donc on est on sait les physiciens
savent de quoi ils parlent quand ils
vous disent avec le carbone 14 on peut
pas datés à plus de 50 milles ans ils
savent ce qu'ils disent
1 la demi vie du carbone 14 ne vous
permettra pas d'aller plus loin que ça
donc à la la la c'est la fin si vous
comprenez pas si c'est ce que j'aime
vous dire vous suffit pas à comprendre
pourquoi on peut pas dater au carbone 14
carbone 14 un tract aux sciences voilà
je fais une vidéo exprès qui explique
pourquoi on ne donne pas les dinosaures
au carbone 14
voilà et vous avez la vidéo de sciences
et aux notes qui vous explique tout la
physique qui a derrière
donc voilà vous avez une vidéo courte
qui vous explique pourquoi en cinq
minutes et vous avez une vidéo longue
ici de sciences étonnante qui vous
explique tout la physique qui a derrière
et pourquoi ces crétins de pas dater les
dinosaures ou des trucs encore plus
vieux comme ça au carbone 14 dh qui sont
proches des âges biblique
cinquante mille ans tu peut réviser je
pense que tu peux retourner lire la
bible s'te plaît et me 50000 en ont
donné mon nom l'âge alors on va regarder
du coup déluge biblique
alors en six ans de la vie de nos et
2600 ans avant la naissance du 2300 48
ans avant la naissance du christ ouais
j'ai pas envie de faire des maths vous
pouvez pas juste me dire que c'était ya
6000 ans merde bref deux mille ans avant
jésus christ dans 2000 ans a fait pas si
milan du coup ça fait quatre mille ans
du coup deux mille ans avant
jésus-christ vu que jésus clé c'était il
ya deux mille ans en 2021 alors
exactement où donc voilà donc le délice
biblique
c'était donc il ya 4000 ans je vous
avais dit que j'avais pas envie de faire
des maths 4000 en deux alors maintenant
dans la tête des créationnistes 4000 ans
et 50 mille ans c'est la même chose
south beach
non non non non il ya beaucoup trop de
charbon pour l'expliquer avec une seule
phrase du christ amel accepte je la
dérive des continents
[Musique]
dan cole south africa oh zut des dépôts
de charbon en afrique du sud
très très loin de là où ta forêt géante
se trouvait et en chine
tu crois qu'ils en ont du charbon en
chine à bari à ça quand on lit que des
bouquins qui parle de la géologie locale
on en oublie qu'il ya de la géologie
ailleurs ce qui veut bien dire qu'il y
avait plus d'un événement de
transgression marine entre chaque couche
de charbon ce qui veut bien dire qu'il
ya une usine inondations rappelé tout à
l'heure comme c'était un problème que
les racines pouvait pas aller en dessous
du de la couche d'argile
maintenant il ya aussi une couche de
calcaire qui vient se rajouter une
couche de degré non c'est pas ça qui l'a
dit je sais plus mais bref il ya
maintenant il ya une couche de calcaire
qui vient se rajouter entre entre chaque
abbas avait eu peut-être le problème
c'est cohérent aussi avec l'idée que la
mer soit tiré venait se retirer le jeu
se retirer revenait par dessus un bassin
minier mais évidemment ça ça implique
qu'ils aient plus d'une inondation donc
c'est pas cohérent avec lingibé biblique
c'est dommage
pessis 300 millions d'années pour la
déposition du charbon mon cul non le
fait que les espèces ne change pas du
début à la fin des dépôts de charbon en
partant du principe qu elles ne changent
pas ce qui n'est pas vrai déjà de base
mais bon on va partir du principe
qu'elle ne change pas pour pas trop le
contredire en tout cas les genres à la
limite ne change pas trop les espèces
change complètement
mais les gens ne changent pas trop et le
fait que ces genres ne change pas ben ça
vient du fait que ça s'était posé très
très rapidement pas en 100 millions
d'années comme il vient dire 100
millions d'années
ça vous amène ça vous amène au milieu de
ça vous amène au milieu du permien qua
non mais pas au début du trias 1 240
millions d'années
ça vous amène au trias je vais dire il
ya une raison pour laquelle le
carbonifère s'appelle le carbonifère
c'est parce que toutes les roches
carbonifère se trouve dans le
carbonifère le carbonifère c'est là
c'est qui contient le charbon donc il ya
une raison pour laquelle cette période
s'appelle le carbonifère et c'est parce
que ben c'est là que se trouve le
charbon est encore tout le carbonifère
n'a pas de charbon c'est essentiellement
le geste va liens et le pennsylvanien
donc ces deux 2 6 étages du carbonifère
qui contiennent le charbon et c'est pas
tous les matins n'ont pas été formés en
même temps c'est à dire qu'il ya des
bassins
le bassin minier du nord de la france
n'est pas contemporain des bassins
miniers de 2 du sud de la france comme à
saint-etienne par exemple donc bien même
mais bref
donc c'est des mensonges tout ça c'est
des mensonges et des conneries voilà si
les bassins miniers avaient duré 100
millions d'années ça veut dire qu il
s'étendrait du carbonifère jusqu au
trias or c'est complètement contraire à
l'idée même qu'on a nommé un étage le
carbonifère le bien même ça c'est pas
logique donc ce mec est complètement à
l'ouest totalement à l'ouest ça a du
sens aussi si tu t'es complètement
planté était complètement en train de
nous miche donnée sur la durée de
dépositions ce qui est le cas quelle
taille elle fait à forest pour survivre
100 millions d'années sur de l'eau salée
[Rires]
vous rappeler que la fal de ja et comac
alors honnêtement ça a été une très très
longue vous rendez compte que la moitié
de la vidéo c'était ça la moitié de la
vidéo c'est sa théorie bullshit sur
comment le son continent flottant
explique explique un tout petit ainsi du
problème afin de faire ce que tout ça ça
résout juste la question
tout ça ça ne fait que résoudre la
question pourquoi on voit les plantes
les plus primitives d'abord et les
plantes pour arriver ensuite
tout ça c'est juste pour expliquer ce
tout petit aspect du problème c'est à
dire le mec il vient de passer quarante
minutes là dessus mais dieu a créé des
dieux du il a créé des fiches apod
comédie dont des poissons des poissons à
pattes d'huile à créer des fiches ipod
et ils sont pas allés dans l'arche de
noé
et si tu avais raison ils sont venus
déposer dans un environnement marin ce
qui n'est pas le cas on a des
environnements lagunaire et des environs
à continental autres déchets c'est
maintenant a expliqué des sédiments
marins soucier quand il ya des sédiments
marins aussi seront n'est pas le cas des
bassins sédimentaires et les
charbonniers de saintes était enfin don
du centre de la france et de subir la
france j'irais google et bassani manqué
bassin par annick ce que lui n'a pas
fait visiblement et googlers bassanini
des bassins par annick lui n'a pas violé
ils cherchent à savoir si la raison sans
faille et cherche à montrer qu'il a
raison pas à savoir
[Musique]
best buy deux fois donc si la raison
lorsqu'ils viennent nous expliquer c'est
qu'en gros pour lui la première phase du
la première phase donc que nous on
appelle le paléozoïque c'est en fait la
phase où le déluge a tué les espèces
marines jamais il nous explique comment
un déluge tu des espèces marines mais
admettons donc est pour lui du coup la
forêt compte comme une espèce marine
parce que c'est une parce que cette
forêt lt flottante
vous noterez que là c'est une grosse
rustine dans sa théorie est ensuite
lorsqu'on appelle le mésozoïque du coup
c'est la partie où là le déluge commence
à emporter les faune terrestre un bon
donc ça veut dire que si je trouve un
seul faux cils continental dans la phase
marine de son de son délire là ça veut
dire qu'il a tort n'est ce pas bon bah
alors prenons le permien badistes rose
au risque au hasard voilà donc fossiles
du père vient donc de la fin du
paléozoïque donc techniquement de la
phase marine à 10,3 hors us il ya des
gens qui ont dit qu'il était peut-être
semi-aquatique bomba d'accord alors
c'est lui ro zohra vue je crois que je
vais mal écrit mais c'est pas grave
c'est le rose aura dû lui il vivait au
père bien mais il a des ailes à vous à
l'époque c'était un petit lézard qui
planait il n'a pas de palme mur ilaria
il a juste des ailes donc lui ben là
pour le coup c'est lui rose aura vu la
zéro change 1 qu'il était autre chose
que terrestres pour monter un petit peu
carbonifère à aller on remonte un petit
peu au carbonifère alors carbonifère
qu'est ce qu'on a
ilo nommé
hop aux îles aux normes us petit lézard
terrestre du carbonifère on remonte
encore un petit coup allez on compte
encore un petit coup bon ben alors
attends attends au dévonien ou
démoniaque est ce qu'on a comme fausse
terrestre arcueil au terrisse alors
c'est pas une faune là pour le coup
c'est de la flore archéoptéryx ya lors
du couac terrisse peut-être oui arterris
archéoptéryx donc qui est un arbre donc
c'est pas une c'est pas un algues c'est
pas une algue année vous allez me dire
ça il peut il fait peut-être partie de
son océan flottant imaginaire devrions
donc non cambrian fendi cambrian
terrestrials fang et voilà on va
directement surtout quand briand tout ce
que j'en ai marre quand brillante et
donc voilà il ya c'était cette année le
22 janvier 2000 il a juste pour vous
montrer quelque chose de relativement
récent voilà on l'a enfin on a découvert
un champignon donc alain guy dans des
dépôts terrestre du cambrien ce qui
montre bien qu'il y avait des dépôts
terrestre déjà dès le cambrien de toute
façon on savait déjà qu'ils avaient
détecté reste au cambrien mais comme de
toute façon il a inventé sa théorie
bullshit de l'île flottante 9
j'ai envie de dire que c'est la théorie
qui était avec et irréfutables parce
qu'en fait à chaque fois qu'on veut lui
montrer un caillou en lui disant mais
regarde tiab a un truc tout bête 10
continuity et aux jeunes
au dévonien donc on va lui montrer et
voilà les surfaces d'érosion dans ces
roches donc surface d'érosion ici qui se
forment à l'intérieur de roche qui sont
ensuite recouvertes par d'autres roches
qui datent aussi du paléozoïque voilà
donc si on a des surfaces d'érosion à
l'intérieur de ton truc ça veut dire
qu'il ya eu les surfaces des versions et
ça veut dire qu'il n'y avait pas que des
roches sous l'eau enfin bref ça veut
dire que tu as tort voilà il n'a jamais
à aucun moment dans cette vidéo
démontrer qu'il ya eu un événement
global
je le rappelle qu' il n'a pas il ya
aucun moment où il nous a montré qu'ils
avaient la même structure géologique
d'un côté à l'autre du du monde
à aucun moment il n'a démontré sa à
aucun moment il n'a démontré que l'eau
en question était de l'os purement
marines aims je le rappelle qu' il ya
des dépôts lacustre il va falloir
pouvoir expliquer comment ça se fait
qu'on a des dépôts d'eau douce on a des
dépôts définitivement d'eau douce enfin
les expliquer comment cela peut exister
dans un angle dans son petit monde rêvé
à lui à aucun moment il n'a démontré que
ses dépôts étaient catastrophiques
au contraire il parle de préservation de
très bonne préservation préservation
exceptionnellement bonnes ce qui est
totalement contraire à l'idée qu'on se
fait d'un dépôt catastrophique et enfin
quelque chose qui a détruit tout qui a
détruit tout encore une fois sauf le
système racinaire de spécimens bridge
donc c'est la suite quatre points de ses
quatres coins là il en a démontré aucun
c'est quelque chose qu'il a admis à
priori et c'est tout et il n'a jamais
démontré que ça a eu lieu à l'époque de
noël
je vous remets juste juste là le moment
où il le maire en plein écran pour parce
qu'il a quand même dit in the days off
mort il ya dix in the days of no à
regarder ces dates qu'ils nous
fournissent est lui qui nous les donne
c'est pas moi qui vous les donne c'est
lui qui voulait pas ça c'est les dates
du du déluge de noé
cinquante mille ans voilà ce mec est un
menteur ou est gravement dans l'erreur
mais dans les deux cas vous ne devriez
pas l'écouter vous êtes trois cent
cinquante mille à avoir vu cette vidéo
vous êtes 5000 à l'avoir leaké shame on
you voilà c'était des mêmes kg pénitence
la pénitence fut dur la pénitence fut
longue
un peu comme ma planète à bientôt